so we already heard that up in the
Northeast
National Guard would be deployed to
drive school buses due to the driver
shortage we're hearing just across the
pond over in the UK they're preparing to
deploy their army because there's no
more truck drivers to deliver petrol and
now there's huge lines outside of stores
Panic buying and now we heard the
governor of New York say the vaccine
mandate is going into effect tonight
which means many nurses will be
terminated when asked what will you do
to alleviate the shortage she said that
she's going to enact an executive order
giving her the authority to do a variety
of things one of which would be to
deploy medically trained National Guards
to fill many of these roles now of
course there are a lot of people who are
cheering for this and blaming the
unvaccinated but this is the government
continually putting National Guardsmen
into private sector roles because I can
only say it seems like we're in a
downward spiral things are kind of
falling apart not to mention we got the
whole gas shortages here in this country
driver shortages labor shortages food
shortages you can't even go to some
restaurants because they don't even have
chicken in some places now they've
switched from like well I can't remember
what commercial it was they were like we
don't have wings anymore we have thighs
because there's a Wing shortage I don't
know how that's going because it seems
like it's kind of gotten a little bit
better in some areas but still seems to
be getting overall worse and now we got
this 3.5 trillion dollar budget the
Republicans are saying we're not going
to sign off on it but maybe just a
stalling tactic so we have to figure out
what all this means and we got an expert
to help us understand what all this
means my understanding is that you're a
Doctor Robert Murphy you have a PhD in
economics that's exactly right yeah
other joke as ahead I'm not the doctor
that helps people it's one of those phds
it's a PhD oh yes do you want to just
quick introduction sure sure um thanks
for having me I'm uh Robert Murphy
Senior fellow with the mises Institute
um author of the book Choice put up by
the independent Institute and most
recently of uh called the common sense
the case for an independent Texas oh
okay interesting so I think you'll have
some really good insights on government
Authority and overreach as well as
economics which will perfect for what's
happening in the news today so thanks
for hanging out thanks for having me we
got Ian oh hello everyone Ian crosson
here happy to be here good to see you
Bob Tim Lydia hello hello speaking of
Lydia I'm also here in the corner and I
was telling Bob earlier that between
being a Libertarian and being an
economist he has something to say about
everything that's happening today so I'm
very excited for this conversation yeah
there's a lot going on creepy stuff
um Joe Biden sang 98 got to get
vaccinated before we can finally you
know wind things down it's like oh okay
before it was 70 then it was 80. but
we'll get in all that stuff before we do
my friends we have an amazing new sort
of new sponsor go to drink right and
feelwell.com to get 51 off of biotrust's
Eternal Reds this is a powdered mix of
eight super fruits beets and berries and
vitamin C it tastes amazing so if you're
if you're someone if you're someone who
wants to get all that nutrition from
eight different superfoods like beets
and berries strawberries blueberries
grapes and all that stuff mix it right
into your drink then go to drink write
and feelwell.com especially at a vitamin
C and I'm not going to pretend to be a
nutritionist but I have read a bit about
how people aren't getting enough so we
actually we got this here's what
happened we got this sent to us and it
was like sample this product and we
ended up making this drink which is a
half ounce of lemon juice a half ounce
of water a half scoop of the Eternal
Reds topped with club soda and it's just
absolutely delicious and so after we
made this we're all excited I was like I
would love you know to shout them out
because this is really really awesome
especially with getting vitamin C
normally I have these like gummy candy
chewies I don't like eating them because
it's candy there's a lot of sugar in
them it's got a little bit of sugar one
scoop has got seven grams but we only
use a half scoop for these drinks so
definitely check it out it tastes
amazing you mix it with your water you
can put some lemon juice like we do some
club soda or you can just mix it with
whatever make it taste good I'm sure
it'd be great in yogurt go to drink
write and feelwell.com 51 off and you
will get a 60 day money back guarantee
free shipping on every order over fifty
dollars in gifts with every order and
for every order today bio trust donates
a nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kidhungry.org to date BioTrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
Hungry kids please help BioTrust hit
their goal of 6 million meals this year
you get free VIP live health and fitness
coaching from BioTrust team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order their new e-report the
top 11 foods that boost circulation and
again 51 off when you go to drink
writeandfeelwell.com and this is like
the third product from BioTrust that
we've been shouting out because they've
been awesome we like their products all
of them from the collagen the keto and
now especially this this was the one we
were most excited for because we're
gonna make we're making a like skate
park healthy cocktail mix
we got all the booze but we want to do
stuff that like will Revitalize you
while you're skating on the half pipe or
something so this is the first drink we
made and we are super excited so again
super uh big shout out to BioTrust drink
right drink right feelwell.com but don't
forget go to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a members only segment
coming up after the show usually goes
around 11 or so p.m and as a member
you're supporting all of the journalism
we're doing the people who work for the
company and our massive expansion plans
which
I don't know if we're ready to announce
the crazy thing we're doing next but
well I guess we can say something we we
got we're getting a big piece of land
and uh I think we talked about this with
Luke and it's like somehow public but we
talked about buying a big piece of land
and then building up this area for like
I guess you call it a hacker space but
we've got 50 acres so we can call it
like hacker City where people can build
stuff you know skateboarding biking 3D
printing drones and we're going to be
and and Production Studio as well so we
can do more shows bring more people out
big expansion plans and it's all thanks
to you and your support So share this
video subscribe to this channel let's
talk about the first story
we have this from military.com New York
Governor May deploy National Guard to
assist with Health Care vaccine mandate
now I gotta say first and foremost this
is a a repost essentially from the
Associated Press that AP writes it then
it gets picked up by a bunch of
different Outlets but I noticed that
they're you know based on what Kathy
hochel said governor of New York versus
what their writing and news stories I
think they're kind of playing this soft
she may deploy the National Guard to
assist with Healthcare vaccine mandate
it's not her first plan and it's only in
the event she has to fire all these
people over the vaccine mandate which
sounds like their intent is to do it we
heard something similar in the UK when
they said we may deploy the Army to
drive trucks the UK one of the officials
said we have no plans to do this
but we're preparing to do it you see
it's word games when she comes out and
says that she's going to enact a state
of emergency granting her the power to
deploy medically trained National Guard
because they're going to be firing
nurses I mean that's straight up stating
their intent to do so I don't think it's
fair to then be like they might not do
it anyway well a lot of people might not
do anything you know Michael Bloomberg
comes out and says I'm going to text
soda he might do it we literally said he
was going to do it so let's talk about
what their intent is and and the line
they're drawing as well as how far
they're pushing us towards
authoritarianism so what I see that's
truly interesting about this
and what's happening and I think it's in
Massachusetts I'm not sure maybe it was
Rhode Island where they're getting rid
of the where they're they're not getting
they're sending in the National Guard to
drive uh buses for school for uh school
children
because of the problems caused by the
politicians destroying the private
sector like this is the perfect example
we're going to mandate a medical
procedure with no exceptions no testing
exceptions just straight up do it
without legislate without legislative
approval then when the market collapses
they're going to send in government
agents to replace them
sounds a bit like um you know I don't
want to say fascism because that that's
that's that implies like kind of an
ultra traditionalist this is kind of
like Chinese state communism style yeah
so you're you're an economist Robert
what are your thoughts on uh on this
stuff we yeah what I was going to say is
exactly what you anticipated that yes
standard operating procedure the
government lays down some legislation
you're saying wasn't even legislation
necessarily just make some rules edicts
yes causes problems and then says oh
well gee now that there's this problem
the free market can't solve it so I
guess we got to come in as the Savior
and I don't like this idea that oh
whenever something isn't getting done
just send in the military because they
know how to do everything apparently and
as we know if you want to get something
done well and efficiently and with
courtesy you send in troops like who
else would you want to be you know
driving your school kids around that's
at the National Guard this reminds me of
a Ryan long sketch where it was antifa
window repair
so it's like they they dress up like
antifone go around in the right smash
windows and the next day show up and say
hey we can fix your windows that's
basically what we're seeing they're like
unfortunately all these nurses have
chosen to do that have have not chosen
to do the right thing oh no now the
government has to come in to clean up
the mess
so we're seeing it with a lot of things
I mean
in terms of the authoritarian takeover
like I don't know if you've been seeing
what's going on in Australia
have you been yeah yeah yeah yeah do you
see this uh videos going viral uh I
don't know if you saw Ian or Lydia where
it's like a guy sitting at a fountain
smoking a cigarette and the cops come up
and just throw them the ground and are
you know they're like there's like seven
cops and they're like You Know This
Woman's yelling what are you doing leave
them alone and he has no reason to be
here it's like he went out for a walk it
wasn't wearing a mask he was smoking a
cigarette and the cops are like we don't
care
so that's that's kind of the direction
we're heading in but it's so it's it's
it's interesting that we're seeing a
combination of maybe it's not
interesting the the government takeover
is hitting both you know the economy and
law enforcement I guess so we're getting
edict and we're getting our we're having
our economy shut down
so yeah my concern Beyond you know the
specifics of this and the Injustice to
the people involved is just the broader
point I to me I think what they're
trying to do is get the public more
familiar with just seeing guys with big
guns walking around you know taking
charge of the situation like moving it
towards what would be called a police
state so something that you know decades
ago Americans would have thought that'll
never happen here in other words they're
not just going to say oh we're doing
this because it's big brother here is
watching you they they can't literally
go from that from Tuesday to a Wednesday
but they do this so you know oh National
Guard well no they're just driving
school buses because you know those
people won't get vaccinated so of course
they got to do that and just get us used
to seeing guys in you know camel walking
around yeah isn't it amazing how kind of
desensitized everyone's become to like a
lot of the stuff I remember I was in New
York and I was walking past Grand
Central Station and the cops that are
there they've they're like fully decked
out in full armor they look like
Stormtroopers and they've got you know
probably selective fire rifles of some
sort and I was just like man that's a
crazy site and they have dogs and
they're like standing next to the end
entrances and I'm like do we really need
that I guess I mean yeah yeah I was so I
went to grad school NYU so in 9 11 you
know I was I was there I mean I wasn't
literally I was across New Jersey but
yeah for uh I think months after I
forget exactly when they phased it out
but yeah there were you know armored
personnel carriers just on the streets
guys walking around with big guns and
you're sort of used to it you know and I
realized like oh this is what America
would look like you know down the road
if if Americans let it go that way and
it looks like they're they are letting
it go that way yeah and then you know
I've been hearing from a lot of people a
lot of uh Military Officers resigning a
lot of police officers are resigned
that's another big story a couple dozen
I guess dozens they say of police in
Massachusetts are resigning over the
vaccine mandates so I mean
can I just ask you and I think you
alluded to it a minute ago the thing
about this that I haven't seen more
people bringing up is just on its
surface so I I understand that yeah
especially in healthcare you know people
with certain conditions they you know
they might be genuinely considered I
don't want you know a nurse dealing with
me who's hasn't been vaccinated but
wouldn't it also be good just to show no
I had this like that I have antibodies
like to me that would be a more
important test to say yeah I had coveted
three months ago I beat it and yet I
don't even see that being discussed well
the let alone like addressed and dealt
with when they say we don't care about
negative tests when they say they don't
care about antibodies
they're saying this is nothing to do
with the infection has everything to do
with control right I mean they can come
out and say all day and night that this
is about public health and I'm like then
wouldn't you actually follow the science
but they don't they don't do that the
science uh the science in many instances
there has been a lot of science that
should and could and should be
questioned yet what do you get
censorship so all right shout out to
Ryan long again because he has a sketch
where uh he just put out today I think
called like trust the experts or
whatever where he comes out and he's
like all the experts agree and then you
know his buddy walks up I think Danny's
the name and he's like I'm an expert and
I read the data and came to a slightly
different conclusion than Ryan
longford's punching him and he's like
shut up and kicking him he's like the
experts agree that's basically what
we're seeing
I was going to say about the police
resigning or vaccine mandates
you mentioned you know people getting
used to seeing you know cops on the
street and things like this it really is
amazing to me how far we've gone where I
can talk to my friends who aren't very
political and I'll say like if I would
have told you three years ago they'd bar
people from leaving their homes that
they'd be mandating you get a medical
procedure albeit a small one I'm not
saying they're going to cut out your
appendix or anything otherwise you can't
work and that you know we'd see
widespread riots and there would be con
nobody would believe it nobody believe
it if I told you that the government
would deploy you know tens of thousands
of National Guards surrounding the
capital with fences they'd be like I'll
get out here if I said there'd be people
starting with no one would believe any
of it it's all been so chaotic people
are desensitized and now we're at the
point where
the good cops who are like you can't
make us do this and this is not
constitutional are all resigning but
there are cops who are staying and those
cops are not going to be the good cops
who are like I'm not gonna you know
enforce that one that crosses the line
what we're going to be left with is a
military of multiple saying like I don't
know just following orders and a bunch
of police say oh just following orders
and then what do we get
yeah I think that's what concerns me too
you know about like the the advertising
like the the you know the woke
advertising for the CIA and all that and
they're that they're making it the case
that after they get rid of you know the
questionables and the people with these
domestic ties and so forth that they're
going to replace them with the right
kind of people who are then going to
implement these because right now you're
right the sort of top-down commands that
they want to eat issue there'd be a lot
of resistance or hesitancy to you know
enforce this stuff but I think they're
looking ahead and saying no we got plans
in places that five years from now the
Personnel Staffing these organizations
are not going to be the ones that were
here so they will follow those orders is
it one thing that's interesting to me to
me though is that often
um powerful interests special interests
politicians use economics as a means of
controlling the system right how do you
make how do you how do you make someone
behave the way you want well you tax
their item Michael Bloomberg was like
we're going to tax large sodas so you
know people are stupid and fat so that
way they won't buy them and things like
that tax cigarettes tax gasoline in this
instance they're going over
authoritarianism you know I wonder if
would you agree they typically is
economic power to pressure people well I
think you're right even in this instance
though in other words instead of washing
just saying every American you know
except for many people certain
exceptions because vulnerability has to
get this vaccine no we're not saying
that we're just saying if you want to
work at a large organization yeah you're
afraid to not have an income yeah so
you're free to go go into the woods
right so even I agree with that you are
yeah and and that's also like with the
big Tech and so like that's part of the
way they're they're doing this as a sort
of end run and there's coercion involved
don't get this isn't like a free market
outcome but yeah I think you're right
that they realize it's easier you know
to get someone to say well my boss is
making me do it and I need my job I got
to support my kids whereas if if we're
just a matter of paying a fine and going
to jail for 30 days they might you know
stand up to the man and this is the
crazy thing about it it's that we've
become uh accustomed to a climated and
uh locked into in a sense right people
are so used to living in climate
controlled homes with refrigerators and
microwaves stoves natural gas easy
access at supermarkets they're like I
can't give that up my kids need this and
I'm like I don't know 300 years ago some
dude was like foraging through the weeds
for food for his family and that that
being said people today don't really
have the ability to go and forage and
farm on their own because land is owned
and controlled by everybody so we're at
this point now
where the planet's basically basically
been labeled you know I claimed by
enough people or interests
that if you did leave your job what can
you do I mean theoretically you can go
to like Sharon and Mexico and then start
figuring things out you can go to the
middle of nowhere but if you have a
family you can't just take a claim
anymore you can't just go to Landing
back okay I'm gonna Farm here and
survive nope they locked you in
so what do you do
well we can start a new career path as a
internet video blogger
so hopefully you did it two years ago
because you know now you don't have much
time to get it going if you're gonna
have to resign from your job that that I
don't know if you saw the conversation I
had with Jack Murphy what was that that
was that was a week and a half ago or so
something he was talking about how his
kid wants to play you know college
sports Varsity Sports and then college
sports and now they're saying well you
got to get vaccinated so he's like it's
tyranny he doesn't think the vaccine is
going to hurt his kid or anything like
that he just thinks the government's
trying to force him to do it and it's a
difficult position where he doesn't want
to tell his kid not to play baseball and
my attitude was like I think you should
tell your kid not to play baseball I
think if you truly believe in it you
should stand up and say I'm not no if
there's you know the government isn't my
doctor and shouldn't tell me you know
what I'm supposed to be doing
the issue you know much bigger than just
baseball is
I saw I saw a video of a
it was a medical worker saying you know
if I have to support my family I can
quit and then we're completely broke or
I can get the vaccine and so they're
like I guess I have no choice and that's
where people are at the government is is
not only
you know I think this is a sign of how
much how how bad it's really really
going to get if they have people so
constrained and so scared that they'll
undergo a medical procedure then what
else can they do get off the central
electric grid for starters get off the
centralized fiat currency grid secondly
so that means crypto solar power grow
your own food get off the centralized
food grid those are three things you can
do homesteading
you know getting get a place on the
middle of nowhere grow your own food get
some chickens fans of chickens have
small companies let's do lots and lots
of small companies yeah but like what do
people do you know like how much work
being done by people is actually
contributing to the lives of individuals
like food production and you know things
like that
fuel most people like to be fair like we
produce
a relatively small amount of
goods for people I mean I guess people
can say that
thought and planning and this is the
kind of stuff that goes into fixing
economies and making people live better
so it's good but like we're not fixing
any toilets we're not growing any bread
we're not feeding anybody so I have many
friends who work in the service industry
whether it's in food or like like I used
to work in a hospital and they're saying
that they're being required to get the
vaccine and when I read the numbers of
Americans who live from paycheck to
paycheck it is not surprising to me at
all that they're able to require this of
people who really don't want it like I
had a Facebook friend who recently got
it and she's like you win Joe Biden
because I didn't I have to do this to
keep my career and I was like that's
really sad you shouldn't have to do that
but I also know that you have three kids
your husband can't work and you know
that if you don't take this shot you
will have to find an entirely different
career this job pays much better than
working as a waitress or something so I
completely understand it's a hard
situation I don't like that we're being
put in it but we're going to figure out
how to stand up to it yes you guys are
right that it's not literally impossible
to you know avoid this stuff but also
too just like you're saying like that's
part of the reason I think that they
monopolize the money supply is because
they knew you know what better way to
put the screws to people right and so
you know they're high income tax and wow
well let me just you know go outside the
standard Health Care System well no you
can't because there's the FDA the CDC
you can't just open up your own hospital
and say hey here people don't need to be
vexed you know so that ultimate would be
the solution in a genuinely free society
that because you know people say oh well
so should my kids not you know what if
they have the measles or something you
know you're against all and it's not
that there's just some all you know from
on high some right thing to do it's like
each each building or each organization
could set its own rules like you're
saying Sports they could decide you know
do the kids you know need to get
something or not whether to participate
and you know they would have certain
uniform requirements or whatever kid
couldn't show up to play naked and play
football you know among other reasons
because that's not sanitary right and so
it's or kids bleeding out or something
and said no know I want to play it's my
decision my dad said I'm fine you know
so there's things to do and the way to
ultimately handle it is not us making a
case by case but to have the
organization set the rules the problem
here is the government has got it's just
tentacles and everything so much that
they can kind of force this outcome so
we have the we have the story out of
Berlin that I think is a good segue
berliner's vote to expropriate large
landlords and non-binding referendum
non-binding okay I don't know if that
really means anything's going to be
accomplished but they do say in the
Reuters article that they say
campaigners hope the city will take
control of some 240 000 departments that
is to say they probably won't but you
have people in Berlin
who are voting that these big companies
that own I think it's 550 000
department-built apartment units lose
control of that and they the public
gains control of it
and the way I see it is it doesn't
matter if it's the private sector or the
public sector when power is centralized
you will get tyranny so what we've been
seeing in the US is like that BlackRock
Fiasco I don't know if you saw a lot
about it this large these large private
investment firms buying up all the
houses offering up insane sums of money
like there'll be a 200 000 house and a
family will be like we'll pay 200 and
then some firm will come in and say
we'll do 230 because we can and we're
rich and we know the value is going to
go up because we're buying it all
you get to that point you're like okay
these these massive out of control
private entities need to have some kind
of Regulation or Anti-Trust
on the other hand
what you see instead is that in Berlin
they're like the government should take
all of them replacing one centralized
Authority with another
so I don't know I I thought this was
interesting For You especially being you
know a mises Institute Economist how
would what's your view on dealing with
massive out of control private
organizations that are seizing the
commons versus you know the left
solution which is government
sure so you had the key phrase there
even out of control so probably if you
would ask me that 20 years ago I would
have said oh well in a free market it's
good that a private Corporation if they
buy it it's not in their interest to buy
it if the price is going to crash later
because then they lose money so they
only buy it if they think it's going to
go up and then that you know rationally
allocates housing to the highest bidder
and that would all be true so long as
they respected property rights and there
was no you know bailouts of them when
they get caught with their pants down
but as we see in practice that isn't
what happened like you know the housing
boom years you could say of a lot of
those com those investors why why are
they making such crazy you know why are
banks giving loans to people that they
know you know they call them liar loans
they knew some of those mortgages that
they were going to people who lied on
the application where and when you push
it ultimately it's largely because you
know they they knew they were going to
get bailed out that oh green span and
then Bernanke he wouldn't let the whole
system go down and so there were things
like that in place so I agree with you
in the real world the problem with big
companies doing that is because it's not
just promoting efficiency because if
they make a mistake a lot of times
taxpayers have to bail them out or the
right Federal Reserve and so yeah you're
right the way to solve that problem is
not to then empower the government even
more because they're ultimately the ones
that you know keep that corrupt system
in place yeah that's what's funny it's
like uh we were talking about this in
the previous segment that the government
comes in and says we're going to fire
all the nurses oh no what do we do well
I guess we'll send in the National Guard
it's like what you chose to do all of
those things so you destroyed the
economy men say here's my Solutions like
you punch the guy in the face and not
from the first aid kit it's like no no
that's not acceptable you can't do that
and in this capacity you get these uh I
can't speak for for Germany but in the
U.S my understanding was that a lot of
these in large investment firms were
getting bank loans and government
funding and fed dollars we're buying up
the property and their attitude was like
we don't care we'll get bailed out if it
screws up so we're stealing from you no
matter what right exactly so yeah in a
you know in a genuine free market it I
would have no problem in principle with
them doing it because the only reason
they would buy it is if they think the
price is going to go higher and it's in
their interest to not be consistently
wrong about that and if the price does
go higher than they did a service by you
know reserving that for the person who
wanted it more down the road but you're
right but what do you what do you do if
one company owns eighty percent of the
property and the more like so the more
property they own the more profit they
generate the more property they buy
until eventually one company owns every
like all the houses in a city or
something
okay so again so long as they're not
violating contracts they're not you know
stealing from people or whatever you
know they're just buying and then
they're only they're respecting you know
the title that they actually acquired
legitimately the only way they could
capture such market share is if somehow
they're out competing all the all the
other you know speculators and housing
developers who are trying to do that so
they're like back in the day the reason
Rockefeller got so big was he genuinely
came up with efficiencies and delivered
kerosene and you know patrolling at
lower prices and so then later you know
people could argue they did stuff with
their money that they shouldn't have
that wasn't a market outcome but
originally that's how he beat his
competitor so per se I don't have a
problem with that so if some company
just starts taking over because you know
they're really good at saying No this
property is going to go up and they have
a better Eye For Real Estate you know I
wouldn't want them to stop doing that
but yeah I mean certainly at some point
you just have a multi-billion dollar
fund saying I don't care if it goes up
I'll buy it anyway because I can because
it doesn't affect our bottom line and
the more property you have the better
and in fact you know once they control a
substantive portion of the market can't
they then manipulate the market like
would there be a would there need to be
a point at which the government can do
something
uh so I I would reject the idea that at
some point they don't care like I don't
think Warren Buffett buys stocks because
I don't care where they go up or down
because I'm so rich now you're right he
might be able because he's so big now to
do things like the fear of fact that
he's you know likes a stock that might
make the price go up and so that does
kind of change you know the analysis
it's it's it's it's it's definitely true
they don't care it's not that they don't
care about like like I'm saying they're
like oh no I'm going to lose money but
don't care it's mostly that they're like
look if I can afford to buy 10 houses
yeah one of them might go down but
whatever you know like I'm gonna
diversify I'm gonna buy as much as I can
and hope that overall out of out of my
ten houses six gain in value and if the
four that go down hopefully the gains
outweigh the losses
so then you'll end up with someone
saying you know what this might be a
risky buy but I can handle the risk
because I've got such massive wealth
from all the property I own already I
can take the risk a regular person can't
do that so then you end up with an
organization that can come in and say
two hundred thousand thousand dollar
house for this middle class working you
know this working family we'll give you
210 and then the seller is going to be
like 210's better for me but then what
happens when the middle class doesn't
own any wealth they can't transfer
anything their kids you end up with like
Chinese style state communism
so so I I suppose you know to go back
you had asked me you know at some point
is it Justified for the state to come in
and so I guess what I would say is I
mean we can quibble about you know
scenarios where you know even I might
say yeah I don't that makes me
uncomfortable but to me you don't make
things better by saying let's have you
know those people in Washington because
we can trust them to do the right thing
and I know you're not saying that but
you're not the same people that are
doing all the stuff that we're talking
about with the National Guard and the
you know vaccine mandates and whatnot
they're not going to come in and all of
a sudden be on their best behavior when
it comes to regulating the housing
sector like they're again they're the
ones who are behind the bailouts in the
first place I'm saying like you know is
Anti-Trust feasible you know the problem
I see with the Berlin thing is like the
government just taking the houses is the
same problem as the corporations having
the houses the only difference is who
you're yelling at but what if they said
hey you know we're gonna we're gonna put
a limit on how much property you can own
or something like that or or perhaps
it's like you're a special case you are
the one company that owns 60 of the
property is we think that's too much so
we're gonna we're gonna antitrust you
we're gonna break you up like what's
your thoughts on that so uh Tom
delorenzo's done a lot of good stuff on
this people want to look him up on
Anti-Trust
um so I don't have the statistics off
the top of my head but I think it's true
that in the vast majority of actual
Anti-Trust lawsuits are brought by the
competitors of like the dominant firm so
it's not you know some disinterested
Civic rights organization you know guys
that are you know just doing this and
they're they're getting money from uh
contributors or something around the
country it's the competitors who try to
bring them down and also what there were
plenty of cases where companies were
viewed as Untouchable you know behemoths
that then just Collette like IBM there
was a period where they just Dominate
and knowing who could ever touch IBM and
then Microsoft came along and then who
could possibly touch Microsoft then
Google no one can touch Google you know
what I'm saying and so a lot of times
like the the stuff gets hung up in the
antitrust lawsuit and the company loses
market share just because of Market
Force I mean to be fair those examples
are just escalating tyranny though you
know IBM was making computers people use
computers like that's a great utility
Microsoft came along and then things
started to get a little shady with how
they were running their business Apple
comes along similar things and now we're
at the point where Google is just
overtly evil and uh censoring new
censoring conversations stopping regular
people from being able to have
conversations it's to the point where
Google got so powerful that
no one can even rise up to challenge
them because if you're a politician or
the music is a good example Wikipedia
says you guys are you know it smears you
in Ridiculous Ways we're at the point
where these institutions have become so
powerful and Untouchable uh that they
can outright just destroy anyone who
would speak up against them to stop them
from abusing power you know so my view
is
I I think we definitely I definitely
lean more towards freedom and everything
but I would say I'm rather Centrist in
the economic scale simply because while
I don't think the government owning land
is going to improve things for the
working class I think centralization of
authority and power regardless of
whether it's government or Corporation
is a bad thing and so how do you decide
how do you break that apart and
decentralize it especially when you know
look Google is Untouchable and as you
said many of these Untouchables have
have waned I mean Microsoft is still
there and Bill Gates is buying up all
the Farmland so he's certainly retained
all that power then you've got Apple
which did a really great job of
rebranding Unix and selling it back to
people for for well let's be real Ian
Unix was open source right it is open
source so he Brands he takes the Unix he
Brands it and then makes it private
sells it for a massive profit
convince a bunch of people that shiny is
better and then I have to deal with
people who don't know how to use basic
you know functions on a PC or or run you
know basic programs because they're
using you know iPhones and stuff no
offense to the iPhone and Apple users
I'm not a fan and now you're at the
point where once like all that stuff
keeps happening now you get Google and
Google's got its tentacles and
everything to the point where
you're uh uh conservative talk show host
and they delete your video because you
cited the CDC that's Stephen Crowder so
now if you can't even speak up against
them any meaningful way oh of course we
can say Google's bad like on this show
but what if you actually want to
challenge their goals and agendas or
something that might affect their their
profits all of a sudden now they're
coming after you they're going to censor
you now you can't even do anything to to
stop it I'm seeing now that Unix might
actually be closed source and the Linus
torvalde reverse engineered it and
created Linux which is open source I
don't know I thought it was open source
okay my my info on that episode that's
kind of big apology example thanks guys
so yeah I I definitely agree with you
that what Google's doing right now is is
you know they're not living up to their
model right uh oh they got rid of that
model okay it's alphabet it's good they
own Google okay right yeah that is like
crazy technology evil Quantum Computing
they're gonna they're gonna I mean
we live under the boot of Zuckerberg and
and alphabet you know Bill Gates yeah so
I I do think that you know 30 40 years
from now it's not just gonna be
politicians that we're going to think
that the humans of that era are going to
think are the ones like running the
world it will be like a fusion of big
you know billion multi-billion dollar
corporations and then powerful states
and it'll be more of a hybrid thing and
that will be considered like the you
know the center of Oppression Chinese
style yeah capitalism communism sure
State Common I don't know whatever term
you want to use yeah so that thing all I
would say though is the way to slow the
movement towards that is not to give you
know the ant the Department of Justice
more power to break up companies you
know so it's a modest point that I'm
making I'm I'm more just you know saying
right right this is not the path but so
I've been thinking a lot that politics
is not what we think it is anymore it's
not Democrats Republicans I mentioned
this before the show that's the skin
suit of politics politics now is
computer software code it's deciding
what we see how we behave who we
interact with so we need to rewrite the
code if we want to control and change
the politics it's not going to happen
from Washington it's going to be a
decentralized movement and it kind of is
well that's that that's a great Point uh
I think Politics as we see it right now
is a facade
when you can't even go on social media
to the Public Square to the water cooler
and say here is my political opinion Ben
there is no democracy there is no
Democratic institution it's quite
literally I I we've mentioned this
before imagine it this way
we get locked down we're told we can't
go to bars we can't go to restaurants so
no one's talking to each other
how are we communicating on Twitter what
is Twitter doing Twitter was censoring
news that that harmed Joe Biden's
campaign
so when you have the interests of a
private Corporation saying we can
control what you see and hear your
politics your vote completely
meaningless there's there there could be
large swaths and there probably are of
people in this country with a very
particular political opinion and they're
going to be like oh I can't bring that
up because you know if I trial get
censored so I'll opt not to say it out
of sight out of mind there's that saying
from Harriet Tubman I believe it was
Harriet Tubman or I believe it's a real
it could be apocryphal I have freed many
slaves I would have freed many more If
Only They knew they were slaves if
people don't know what they don't know
it just never comes up and so when you
see Twitter censoring the hunter Biden
story
that overtly benefited the Biden
campaign so how can we say that we have
any kind of real political system if if
that's what we're living under and I I
agree with you you know giving the
government power is no guarantee it's
it's no it that they're not going to
solve it right we could cross our
fingers and be like well what if we said
okay you can break up these companies
they say oh okay we'll break up all the
enemies of Twitter so Twitter becomes
the dominant company and you you look at
what they do to parlor what they do to
gab the government will just use their
power to benefit their Coke their
collaborators in the private sector
right exactly and so I don't have a
great answer for okay well then what do
we do so for sure though I just want to
be clear I'm not saying hey they're a
private company they do whatever they
want like that's not what I'm saying but
I am saying that let's be realistic
partly you know why these corporations
do pose a threat is because they're in
League with states that have you know
armies and prisons behind them and you
know Monopoly printing presses so that's
you're not gonna like empowering one to
you know keep the others in check that's
certainly not uh right a good solution
yeah so we'll probably have like a star
link decentralized internet that's runs
parallel with this corporate internet
and then we'll be able to have like
decentralized Finance the problem is the
military if the government controls the
military it's kind of like we are the
government so we give these people
authority to make commands for us but we
don't have to do that this stupid this
governor in New York that was like I
have signed paperwork to give myself the
power
no that paper ridiculous statement ever
power is granted it is not
going back to what you were saying Tim
my friend um took a a picture and a New
York City subway I think I'm getting
this right and it was a three-pane thing
you know it's from like the CDC or
something or the or the New York version
of the Board of Health and the first
pain show two people talking without
masks on yeah I saw that and it said bad
and then the middle pain shouldn't
talked with the mass better and then the
best was them texting each other and
yeah to me that had nothing to do with
transmission of a virus that had to do
with get people talking through the
thing that you're right they control the
flow of information I have uh I have
just written a decree oh granting myself
the power to declare Ian must make me a
loaf of bread Oh I thought you were
going keto but I can't I can't defy that
order I can eat the bread isn't that
insane if you can just declare you have
the power to do it did you have the
power to do it the entire time that's
how insane this is they're voted into
office to represent us and can be voted
out at any moment
that's
um the thing is the military the thing
is the military and satellite
intervention if they can watch you from
above and see if you're farming on your
land and then come in with military
that's messed up
so where does this all lead to I mean
this is probably one of the most
pessimistic you know conversations we've
had in a while it's like you know Ian
you make a good point about there's like
the politics is not what we think it is
yeah that's kind of just distracting us
I I feel like that's the bread in the
circus where it's like who's going to
win the election you can pick of our
approved candidates and you get the
Republican who says we'll wait a little
bit and the Democratic says burn it all
down and then what happens is you vote
for republicans and they go oh okay
we're gonna resist uh we'll be sleeping
over there you get the Democrat and
they're like great time to start
knocking stuff over so there's no real
resistance at all and I think that's why
they just absolutely despise Marjorie
Taylor green and Lauren bobert not to
say that they're you know
changing the game either maybe they're
just louder voices but still not enough
to actually make it make a difference
here right and I think that that
explains just the hostility to Trump you
know whether people love them or hate
them that he was so out of the mains
like he actually was not playing the
game according to the standard rules
like normally the Republicans like we're
so sorry we're so success and racist but
please you know give us a chance because
we're better on economics than them and
Trump was not playing that game and was
going around and so that's why it was
just code red establishment in both
parties you know National Review had a
whole issue against Trump I think people
some people forget that that
conservative Inc was not pro-trump in
the beginning they didn't like him
either he was too much of a you know
wild card and whether he wasn't playing
the game that they had wanted to play
too so uh and you know and I'm not
singing praises to Trump I'm just saying
that you could see how the system is
what it is and they like that yep here's
two candidates it's you know shade of
gray or a shade of gray this way choose
and now you're free because you got to
pick a person every four years and to me
yeah that's why now I I think States
breaking away or you know cities or what
have you is the only near term to
midterm way to do anything it has to be
super subtle because if they think that
you're breaking away they'll come in
with a boot but if you just do it with
parallel systems that's synergize I
think it can happen I don't know man I
think we're we're getting to the point
where they're losing the ability to
control the systems the way we we think
they would
New Hampshire for instance the free
state project I mean these guys are
getting more and more people on board
with seceding from the union now will
that happen
I I think it's highly unlikely but what
happens when you have the free state
project saying everybody come to New
Hampshire sign a pledge saying we out
what happens when 80 of New Hampshire is
like yo we out and then what happens if
there's like Mass non-compliance with
the federal government's laws the feds
don't have enough people to go in and
deal with like I think New Hampshire
only has like 800 000 people in it not
many yeah yeah do you want to check the
yeah population but I mean how is the
how is the federal government going to
deal with 800 block the highways or
something we're like What do you do and
it's not just New Hampshire it's other I
mean Texas Texas has constantly pushed
those buttons I don't know what do you
think you think Texas would ever get to
that point yeah I do actually I think
it'll be sooner than a lot of people
think
um and and you're you're right it's to
me what they like just hypothetically
speaking Yeah if if two-thirds of Texans
voted in a referendum that we want to
break away it would be difficult as the
U.S lectures the world about
self-determination you know what if they
just started reading them the
Declaration of Independence to them and
so what what part of this do you not
agree with anymore you know and you know
and it would be important too
to not have any you know no violence
suggested just to say no we're breaking
away so that if Washington starts
ordering the Air Force to bomb them it's
going to be pretty clear-cut what
happened right so this is the thing you
know people often say oh the government
the feds would never allow secession
because they would go send the military
in and I'm like that would make people
more uh like supportive of secession
right they would see the aggressor being
the federal government going in and
rounding people up they'd see crying
babies and screaming women and be like
this is crazy like they didn't even do
anything and the uh I think more and
more people would actually actually it's
it's not too similar from the American
Civil War with Fort Sumter when the
fighting broke out I think it was seven
other states that were like whoa that's
crazy we're out and then word traveled
way slower in the era of fourth and
fifth generational Warfare you gotta
have propaganda on your side which means
often you know you want to be the victim
right you want to be the one getting hit
going oh they're attacking me help me
and then people sympathize with you
so that's why I'm I'm wondering like
what would happen if New Hampshire said
we hereby secede it's done and the
federal government says no you don't
they say don't care not listening are
they going to send in the feds are
collecting taxes or what right so I I
have done been doing research on like
non-violent resistance you know things
like like the Civil Rights struggle just
to give an example of people they had
training back in the 60s where like when
they would do a sit-in and they would
train the people and say okay the mobs
are going to come and start punching and
screaming and spitting at you don't
swear at them and just sit there and
take it and then when you have taken too
much we rotate so the guys on the inside
are the circumference now and they take
you know I mean and that was so it
wasn't just oh let's love everyone no it
was strategic because they knew we're
outnumber you know we have to win public
opinion and then enough people watching
TV are like you know seeing firemen you
know hose down Marchers and you know
yeah I don't know if I'm for that so
you're right with New Hampshire again so
and that's why right now again they're
making this propaganda effort to talk
about oh how the right wing threat and
all these you know what I mean because
they want the public to believe when
they're kicking indoors it's because
there's all these right-wing Kooks who
pose a threat not just people who say
you know what I want to break away and
not not be affiliated with Washington DC
anymore got a number here it's 1.36
million people in uh that's a 2019 1.36
million in uh New Hampshire more than I
thought yeah you know I think saying we
want to break away is like saying I'm
anti that I hate that I I'm voting
against that rather than being against
it you want to say we're create we're
fixing this American system and then all
these people around the country will
start doing it together and that is not
going to be be considered anti if you
say I'm breaking away they're going to
say that's anti-American and now people
would be brainwashed fifth generational
but if you say we're fixing this
together that's gonna that's gonna tweak
their minds and make them join you when
you you know you make a good point all
of this rhetoric about the far right and
everything is getting people ready for
when start kicking the doors down right
they're gonna be like oh you know but uh
New Hampshire
that's going to be a cold splash of
water in the face to a lot of people who
are like wait an entire state is trying
to secede wait a minute I need I'll tell
you this they're not hearing this when
they turn on CNN so right now I assure
you most people like I'd be willing to
bet and uh I I would say this
if I was looking at
two options of voting you know does the
the leftist YouTuber severe breadtube
know about New Hampshire session or
don't they I bet they don't I would say
I will put my chip on they don't know
about this
and they're not paying attention to it
and it doesn't matter to them even
though they're supposedly libertarian
now I think it's fair to say many of
them probably do but I think it's not
part of the conversations they're having
in which case even to those people who
are supposedly like more you know uh
politically oriented
and regular people none of them are
probably seeing the stories in the news
about how I think it's like up to five
reps I think so five or so four five was
last year in New Hampshire who are like
we favor succession that's a tiny amount
relative to the hundreds or so that they
have it's growing but that's a that's a
conversation you think like if you you
would think that the state of Jefferson
that several counties in Oregon voted to
see from the state to join Idaho and
then Northern California that there's a
county in Northern Colorado that wants
to join Wyoming yeah right and that you
know even California's talk about
secession taxes as we talked about
secession New Hampshire is fine the
paperwork Texas filed the paperwork
before and there was a poll I think it
was Hugo data we mentioned often 37.2
percent of Americans favor their region
breaking off from the US to form a new
Regional government I'd be willing to
bet most people don't know about that
and even political leftists don't know
about that if one of these states did
make an actual formal declaration it
would be like them waking up one day
with like the Moon being upside down or
something weird like how are we at this
point if the government came and said
it's far right extremists they'd be like
all one million 1.3 million well it
passed by 60 so you're saying like 700
000 people 800 000 people are all
far-right extremists or is that a whole
state saying yo we out right into Ian's
point I think you're right so with my
you know when I talk about this like I
so we're using the term secession just
because it's very precise and we all
know you know I'm sure your audience is
very informed but I would call it like
the Texas Independence Movement you know
it's the same thing just like
technically the Fourth of July they
seceded from Great Britain but we
consider it Independence Day I just
thought a good way to do it would be if
you set up a smart contract so that your
government secedes until your demands
are met the demands could be whatever
you want so like repeal the Federal
Reserve if the US government does that
we'll come back into the country and
then you could have a bunch of different
communities secede at once with smart
contracts set up ready to reunify
you wouldn't need smart contracts the
problem is confidence
if people uh you you guys have seen for
Vendetta I assume yeah you know that
scene at the end where you know the the
um what's the name of the inspector I'm
not gonna ask home or whatever I don't
remember he's like eventually someone
will do something stupid and then it
shows the uh the the finger man they
call him and he shoots a little girl and
then all of a sudden everyone starts
walking up to him they have pipes and
he's like ah holding his badge but they
don't care because that is the point
where people no longer have confidence
in the system
in the beginning of the movie when
Natalie Portman's character says oh God
your finger men that's her saying she
believes in the power of the state and
she fears it the end of the movie is
when people say we don't believe in your
power or care about it so in terms of
you know breaking away seceding peaceful
divorce whatever
if people just don't believe in the
power of an institution it doesn't exist
the reason I bring up smart contracts
with like your state so say New
Hampshire secedes they have a smart
contract ready to bring them back into
the Union when their demands about is
because if some power hungry Monarch
came into power in New Hampshire during
that process and decided yeah you'd
repeal the Federal Reserve but I'm not
coming back now you'd have some strong
man so you want to automate it
you can't automate the process by which
the public would come to trust the
government again yeah it shouldn't be
about trust well it does it doesn't
matter listen the point is if you have
you know uh let's say you got 1.3
million people in New Hampshire and they
do a referendum on secession and 60 say
okay we're gonna vote so you're looking
at you know I guess what would that be
around 600 oh 60 60 so maybe 600 600 700
000 people 700 or so thousand those
people have stated with that vote we
have no confidence in in the system
you can't then just have a system that
automatically turns around one day and
says oh all of you guys who voted
against us you are now back in the
system they'd say no we're not we don't
believe it for me it's not that I hate
the United States and that system but
there are aspects of it I want changed
so as like a as like a I don't know what
you would say like I'm I'm boycotting
this stupid government until you fix
these things I don't want to be gone
from the US forever but I'd be happy to
like you know put pressure them to fix
the system so when you're dealing with
several hundred thousand individuals you
can't just one day snap your fingers and
if all of them agree if 700 000 people
agree we want out no matter what happens
there's no point at which you can just
turn around and say okay now you all
hereby agree to like the state and
believe in its power they're gonna be
like no we still don't believe in its
power I think I guess part of why I'm
pushing this is because I think if they
if they want it out if you really want
to get out of the United States that's
not going to happen the U.S federal
government would demolish any kind of
resistance they would send in the
federal they'd block off I-95 and then
they would I think you need to
understand they have satellites dude
what yeah I gotta have jet planes like
what are you the free the people who are
going up to New Hampshire are not Mom
and Pop like soccer mom you know local
uh mid managers these are people who
want to live in the middle of nowhere
and hunt for their food these are these
are free Staters who are staunch
Libertarians and caps who are going up
there being like good take it all away
get away from me I'm gonna grow my own
food and get water from the ground so if
the feds came in and said we're cutting
off the the you know supply of TVs
they'd be like we don't care
yeah so so I I'm enjoying this
discussion so we to your point that's
why my in my writing about this stuff I
focused on Texas first because they've
got the two oceans and they've got the
border with Mexico it would be harder
and you know it's huge too it would be
harder to seal them up whereas Florida
also there's many respects in which you
might think yeah they should go too you
know to say you know president DeSantis
or whatever but it would be easier to
just do a naval blockade so I agree with
you it would be tricky but again if they
did it peacefully and the only their
only crime was to say we're breaking
away we're not sending money to
Washington anymore and they send in
tanks and starve them into submission
that might be a PR disaster you know and
there would be so much Guerrilla media
like showing oh you know I mean like
right now like American troops doing
atrocities overseas if they were doing
it in New Hampshire that might not play
with a lot of people I mean they that
you'd probably get sanctions on the U.S
all of a sudden massive G7 trade
Partners would be like we will not be
trading with you until you stop doing
what you're doing
now
right they could get away with it if
they found all these right-wing you know
Depots of Munitions and you know what I
mean like if they're the government
could could plausibly claim either
because of the false flag or because
there really were people who decided you
know I'm sick of this they've got MSNBC
it would be a total PR nightmare for the
New Hampshire people it would be
terrible so it would be good it would be
you know uh and they control the
narrative and then New Hampshire the
people would have to appeal to another
country to help them because and then it
would be like who are they going to
appeal to Canada I don't think so China
probably you know the funniest thing
about a New Hampshire secession is it
would basically sever Maine from the
contiguous United States yeah it can't
happen they wouldn't let that happen
right right of course but I I'm curious
as to what their tactic would be
probably I'd imagine at this point it
would be to flood the Zone with money
and resources to drown out any
conversation about a free state but I
got to tell you a Grassroots movement is
something powerful if more and more
people keep flooding up to New Hampshire
for the free state project no amount of
money is going to shut that down right
and it's a very very least that's what I
think it's worthwhile like you know
shows like there's people talking about
it just to because I'm curious to hear
like the people who you know work for
Vox or the New York Times just get them
on record to say hypothetically if
two-thirds of Texans voted to break away
would you let them go or would you think
they should send an air strikes and tank
you know I mean just to have them on
record because how could they say or
maybe they would say yeah we wouldn't
let them do that we're talking about
we're we're at a point
I'd be willing to bet if we went to uh
and poll democrats should Republican
states be allowed to secede they'd say
yes
I think you will see a large portion say
yes let him go now a year ago or there
was a year or so ago there was data from
The New York Times on this and I think
it was something like 30 percent said uh
yes they can go like 60 some odd percent
said overwhelmingly no they can't leave
the union I think that's changed you
know a year on now especially as things
are going I'll tell you this come 2022.
if Republicans end up taking large
portions of the house and they end up
getting control back then you're going
to see the sentiment sentiment flip and
leftists are going to be like get them
out right we already we already saw that
podesta thing from the Boston Globe that
John podesta said the West Coast should
secede from the union if Donald Trump
wins what happens when Trump wins again
Joe Rogan in the news simply for
Stadium's opinion I love how this always
happens Jose says he thinks Trump's
going to run Trump's going to win if
that happens the left is going to be
like how about we let you secede instead
of letting Trump be president and then
what how does that happen right and
that's that's um some of the arguments
I've been making too is to say to like
what's called Blue State voters just for
lack of a better term
suppose it were Texas and they wanted to
break away let them go because all the
people in your state you know if you're
in California or some other blue state
New York whatever A lot of people would
move to Texas then so you get rid of
them you know those gun nuts or the
people who don't want to get vaccinated
get them away from you and go if Texas
did leave the union Democrats would
never lose a presidential election right
for the remaining you know U.S system so
it's kind of a win-win and that's not
like a paradox like you know armies
agree to not use poison gas against each
other you know I mean there are things
that and this would avoid a lot of
conflict so I to me it's I'm not just
trying to like trick the left or
something I'm saying no it's wouldn't
can't we all agree if Texas wants to
leave let them go that's better for
everybody but look we end up seeing
Sarah Silverman comes out on her show
saying maybe we need a peaceful which
say a separation I don't know if she
said divorce did she say peaceful
divorce so they mean she must be
listening to Michael malice because I'm
more into the peaceful separation which
is why I bring up the smart contract
Civil Disobedience angle because you can
leave and then come back when you
divorce it's gone forever now Ian you're
not understanding like we're talking
about if like why do you believe US
dollars are valuable right because you
can go to the store and buy stuff with
you what if one day the clerk said I
don't want your money it's not worth
anything to me it's useless though would
there be one day where you convinced him
no the smart contract change therefore
you have to take it now he'd be like get
out of my store what do you mean what do
you mean by that let's say you have
800 000 people all say one day we no
longer want to accept US Dollars we
think it's valueless
and then you're like but we'll do a
smart contract that says as soon as the
fed's gone we'll all take this back and
then one day the system comes back into
the smart contract flips and now
everyone is mandated to accept dollars
again and you walk into the gas station
do you think that clerk will just change
his mind or do you think he's going to
be like I said I don't take that money
anymore get out
the smart contract will not change
public confidence in a system if the
system if the confidence breaks there's
no reversing it I mean maybe over a few
decades in a few Generations you can
rebuild that network but it doesn't work
I see what you mean that people are
going to do what they're used to doing
regardless of what the law says but if
you could
digitally because they're seeing things
are going digital now if you could just
digitally kind of just change the money
like so you're using US Dollars now
tomorrow you're using Texas dollars and
then when they finally repeal the
Federal Reserve you're using U.S dollars
again
I mean I think that sounds like a pipe
dream I think seceding peacefully it's a
pipe dream because there's no way the
most powerful military that's ever been
ever existed would let a piece of their
economy just walk away I agree like in
Oregon these counties want to secede
like as if Portland's gonna let their
surfs go but
look let me let me pull up this story
all right we'll talk about how bad it is
and maybe maybe the story isn't the
perfect example we got this from from
Daily Mail Republicans block Bill to
avoid the government shutdown Senate
votes 48 to 50 to sink funding bill with
GOP leaving it to Democrats to raise the
debt ceiling
so the U.S is on the verge of default
has this ever happened before
the actual default no yeah the the debt
ceiling happens yeah and the Republicans
always and the Democrats always say like
I'm gonna block you so they can try and
get leverage right so this isn't would
you call this situation like remarkable
in any sense
I haven't seen anything that sets this
apart qualitatively from previous
episodes if that's what you're asking
yeah yeah what would happen if we did
default
so I mean I heard uh you know these what
was it Chuck Schumer was was re I don't
know if it was today or yesterday when
he was going through this oh nine
percent unemployment
no I mean I think the UK government in
the 70s defaulted technically on some
other bot so it's not inconceivable that
even major governments do this and uh so
you know I don't have a crystal ball it
would certainly shock people they're not
expecting the US government to do that
but all that would mean is and people
would be less willing to lend money to
the federal government and since the
federal government my opinion is doing
all sorts of Lawless criminal things
with that money that wouldn't be such a
bad thing if people stopped lending it
money on such easy terms in the future I
have a crystal ball for you one second
okay crystal ball Ian there's like
there's two crystal ball I'm only I'm
only buying if we write up a smart
contract though I want a protection Ian
actually is bringing a crystal ball over
for Robert
oh good is this so you can make
predictions on the economy
[Laughter]
I think it's actually a crystal ball
but um you know I want to bring this up
because
I want to stress it's you know we hear
this all the time like the Republicans
are like we're gonna block it there's a
government shut down everyone rolls
their eyes but right now it's kind of
the worst possible time for this to be
happening there's no Unity we're at a
point now where
healthcare workers are being fired
police are resigning in Mass the economy
is well actually let me ask you this
question is the economy good
no I I think it's all right that's all I
need to do because I like to cite this
metric where Civics data shows that
independent voters Republicans say the
economy is not good Democratic voters
say the economy is fairly good and I'm
like what Universe do these people live
in where they think this is a good
economy when you have 10.9 million job
openings people aren't taking them and
so I look at this and I'm like
there's no there's no Unity even now
amidst this economic crisis shortages
fuel shortages labor shortages that the
politicians are going to are going to
keep playing the same stupid games so
I'm curious if you know I you said you
don't see this as remarkable at all but
I I don't know is is there anything here
to indicate that it's getting worse
so let me just briefly make my
standpoint about Republicans they always
annoy me with this thing because the
Republicans you know for since we you
and I were kids I think we're close in
age they always talk about oh we want to
have a balanced budget Constitutional
Amendment all they would have to do is
not raise the debt ceiling and then you
would have to have a balanced budget
because all that means is the treasury
is not allowed to allow or sorry it's
not allowed to let the amount of
outstanding public debt get higher than
this number yeah and so that means they
can't borrow more money so that means
they would have to run balanced budgets
and that doesn't take constitutional
amount so it just proves they like
posturing and being for small government
or fiscal responsibility but every time
they raise the debt ceiling they're
authorizing more deficit spending I do
feel like we're getting to a point where
there's probably a lot of conservative
voters populists who are like default do
it right so yeah Murray rothberg's
written on this I'm sure other
libertarian economists have as well that
it does at first sound like
irresponsible or somebody saying what
does that mean what what the
government's doing when it doesn't
default it's pointing guns and
threatening jail time to people who had
nothing to do with the transaction to
take money against their will to give as
interest payments to people who
voluntarily bought treasuries who lent
money to the government and so to
default means they're you're not
coercing people to pay to those who
voluntarily lent money to the government
how is that you know so morally that's
not a it sounds like what you're saying
is the right business to be in is
lending money to the government
if they're going to go Point guns at
other people on my behalf hey I'll be on
I'll be on the bet on the back of that
gun inside the front of it sure and
what's funny is even a lot of people who
are very you know like minarchists have
very small government people usually in
terms of the list of things that they
would think the government should stop
you know they was like oh yeah no you
know Aid to foreign countries and you
know the government shouldn't be in
higher education if they'll go down the
list but usually paying interest on the
outstanding debt is something that
everybody agrees the government should
do that and yet that's the one area
where those people volunteer you know
you voluntarily lend money to a
corporation
if they don't pay you back tough and so
hey you lent money to Uncle Sam and now
people don't want to give him more money
and he's got you know a budget crisis
why is it so assumed that you get paid
first what would happen though so if U.S
government defaults on the debt to the
Federal Reserve and they just say we're
not paying you back ever Federal Reserve
goes bankrupt and then the US
government's like here's our new
currency
okay yeah so that's an interesting
question so
um I know you guys know this but just
for the benefit of The Listener so yeah
the a large portion of the outstanding
treasury you know so the U.S treasury
owes money to people they have bonds and
some of the one owner of that is the
Federal Reserve and so what yeah what
people do ask what would happen if the
treasury just said you know what why
don't we just write off two trillion
dollars and we're not paying that
um so technically that would make the
Federal Reserve insolvent they would be
bankrupt you know their assets would be
lower than their liabilities at that
point but they could still create money
electronically I mean I don't think they
would say well The Jig Is up you know
they would just keep operating like the
the 20 trillion uh debt that we owe
isn't that all Federal Reserve notes
uh no so it's it's it consists legally
speaking in bonds so those are
conceptually two two separate
things going on you explain the
difference
sure so
um
if the if the federal government you
know wants to spend two trillion you
know they're going to spend 10 trillion
and they'll have eight trillion in tax
revenue they need to borrow two trillion
extra they issue bonds to borrow those
from lenders and what the people are
holding then is is a bonds you can't go
to the grocery store and buy food with a
treasury bond but the people that are
lending the money to the government
isn't that Federal Reserve notes that
they're lending to the government it's
either electronic or yes technically but
this technically the same notes could be
circulating in the economy and you could
be accumulating treasury debt can you
transfer a treasury bond
what do you mean by that can I like sign
it over to you
yeah so theoretically you could buy
groceries with it you you could if they
would accept but you could buy groceries
with chickens and stuff too exactly yeah
right right so it's an ass it's a very
liquid asset yeah yeah you could but I'm
saying it's not it's not money per se I
guess it seems like it's all Federal
Reserve debt because if you're going to
issue a bond you're the government your
issue a bond to somebody that lends you
money they're just lending you money
that had been printed by the Federal
Reserve anyway okay but by the same tote
like uh if if uh Google issues bonds
technically they're borrowing US Dollars
too that doesn't mean all private sector
debt is just Federal Reserve notes but
all US dollars are Federal Reserve
promissory and you understand like if
the US government says hey Ian if you
sweep my floor I'll owe you 10 bucks
you're at the Federal Reserve they owe
you 10 bucks right or if Tim just lends
you a hundred dollar bill and you sign
something saying I owe you a hundred
dollars he paid you with a Federal
Reserve Note but that's not that that
debt now is you know the property the
Federal Reserve so I'm just saying there
is an interplay don't get me wrong but
I'm just saying conceptually those
they're distinct things but yes if like
you were saying Tim if the if the uh
treasury defaulted on the debt that the
FED owns
it's interesting I mean technically what
would happen is then they wouldn't have
the ability
if inflation gets if price inflation
gets out of hand the way the FED can try
to dampen that is they sell off
debt they're you know their assets to
soak dollars up and Destroy them so they
can't do that as well if some of their
assets disappeared because the treasury
defaulted them so that's part of the
issue is the Fed would be less able to
control price inflation and the other
thing too is and you've got to
understand is that the US has to
maintain confidence in the US dollar and
by military force if necessary so they
wouldn't just ever be like okay fed
we're done we're we're not doing U.S you
know Federal Reserve notes anymore we're
going to do fed coin because then China
is going to be holding a bunch of toilet
paper and they're going to be like hey
we're not trading with you unless you
accept what you've given us or what you
owe us so it's not just it's it's an
interconnected system I mean if the US
wanted to go full-on isolationists
self-sustainability like
just no more conversations oh they could
do that be like hey everybody
congratulations we're issuing you know
America coin that's the currency of this
country US dollars are gone China can
screw itself or what you could do is
every every US dollar that China is owes
or has you could just give them a U.S
coin for and so we'd have like 28
trillion coins to start it's a little
excessive but whatever they got us into
the situation
there are rumors about uh cryptocurrency
have you heard of fed coin yeah what are
they calling it fed coin or what are
they calling it I don't think they're
calling it I think cynics do but it's a
SPC I think uh United States Bank coin I
think yeah I don't I don't know if the
time I had what the official term is
just like QE the FED never called those
programs QE that was like just right
Wall Street dubbed them if uh
when when we when we inflate our
currency when we pump out new dollars
and and stuff like that through
quantitative easing right so how does
that work
okay so the the Federal Reserve just
buys assets electronically and then in
the act of doing that so
If the Fed wants to buy a billion
dollars worth of mortgage-backed
Securities it creates a check
then that check by law clears manifests
right because the the bank you know like
Citibank you know the seller of the
bonds deposits the check from the fed
and then Citibank says to the FED we got
a check from you for a billion dollars
to this client and the FED says yep
that's good so the FED just adds a
billion dollars to the electronic
balance or Citibank and then Citibank
adds a billion to the deposit of that
client so just magically money is fake
the money supply went up by a billion
dollars and so when inflation comes
natural from that I have to imagine you
know China and other countries are like
hey yo what the hell because we have
debt and you're devaluing the debt we
have with you so they get pissed off
about that yeah it's China and other you
know big holders they're in this weird
position where I think they want to
diversify out of it but yet if they just
say to the world you know we don't trust
the dollar anymore then it can crash it
and so it's a weird it's sort of like if
Bill Gates wanted to sell Microsoft
stock you know he'd have to you know go
through a divorce or just divest himself
because of you know charitable concerns
people say that's why it did it correct
me if I'm wrong but what they're there
was a time when in order to expand the
money supply they had to find more gold
when they're making gold coins and
silver they're like if you don't have
the materials to make it you can't make
it right so I'm sure everybody is
vaguely aware of the gold standard and
how you know Nixon ended but actually to
me the really cool period was origin you
know with the Constitutional founding
the late 1780s up through
um the silver right before the Civil War
the U.S federal government did not issue
paper dollars what they did is they said
if you want dollars you have to bring in
a certain amount of raw gold or silver
and we will stamp them at you know U.S
mints into coins that say you know
twenty dollars or one dollar if it's
silver yeah and so the public in a sense
determined the quantity of dollars in
existence
based on those legal rate you know they
announced the ratios especially like the
government was certifying this this was
a true and correct way exactly right so
money so the the money was gold and
silver and like that's how like mises
and other you know economists of the
time thought of it like they thought
money and so and so or sorry gold and
silver were the actual money and you're
right the government all it was in the
Constitution say that right so it was it
that's the thing too like it gave the
government the authority to coin money
it didn't mean to print up Fiat dollars
it meant like it was the same way like
it could set weights and measures so it
could say like 12 inches is a foot you
know I mean just to sort of to allow
Commerce to flourish by having standard
units this is what we mean by a dollar
it's this many grains of gold so the FED
right now can simply say hey Ian you got
a billion dollars and that's it here's a
billion dollars yes but they wouldn't
just give it to them they would buy
something for it because they're not
done right if they're going to get a
billion dollars give it to me though if
I was a friend of a friend or something
they could buy this Crystal Ball from
you and say it's a million dollar or a
billion dollars and buy it and acquire
it and that's the way they could funnel
too what about like my work like a nice
Jolly hello is like I'm I'm now giving
them some advice and they can give me a
billion dollars for that so economically
there would be nothing stopping I think
there might be statutes about you know
they couldn't just pay you for a service
we we talked about this uh on One show
where um I was buying uh I was I was
buying something from a bank
I had to do a y transfer from one bank
to another
and then uh so I bought a truck we
bought a truck for our mobile Production
Studio and then one day I get a call
from this bank and I'm like they have no
business to call me because I settled
that debt but then eventually I decided
to check my messages and they're like
we're calling about an outstanding debt
you have so what happened was Bank a
transfers money I said here's all the
information that was provided for me and
it was all true and correct they say
okay the wire transfer has been
initiated it should clear soon
the other bank that was supposed to
receive it said we never got it we have
never received that that wire
so then I'm like okay so I called my
bank and they're like no we have it
right here written down the money's gone
and I'm like then where's the money
they're like it's gone it just literally
doesn't exist
so how does the South Park episode no I
mean it's literally happened to me a few
months ago if the the banking system is
literally just one Bank writing down a
number and saying you haven't the other
bank writing down a number saying you
don't have it and if One Bank fails to
write down a number then the money is
just gone
eventually I contacted somebody and they
told me you know they ignored me and
then I tweeted about it and that's
that's the magic word in today's you
know fascistic social dystopia where if
you've if you have enough followers you
can tweet your problems away right I'm
fortunate enough to have been able to
been like hey Bank what's going on
where's my money and then immediately I
get like a liaison like we're so sorry
Mr Paul we'll resolve this for you and
then they eventually said okay okay we
we figured it out and don't worry about
it but the crazy thing is for a regular
person
if you have two Banks and One Bank says
we went into your bank and hit delete on
that amount it's gone you can't do
anything about it yeah I mean and there
is in a very legitimate or not
legitimate that makes it sound like it's
okay in a very real sense that like a
bank when it grants a mortgage to
somebody there is a sense in which you
know M1 is that is the term like that's
the measure of the money supply that
that literally went up like the way
economists measure how many dollars are
in existence and so the commercial
banking system can expand and contract
the money supply through lending but
when they were mistakes like in your
case yeah when they do loans that money
comes from nowhere right
right so I mean it's there's constraints
they can't just create a trillion
dollars like there's things that would
happen the reserves will get drained but
but yes strictly speaking there's
nothing in the accounting like when a
bank makes a loan it's qualitatively
different from like if if the bar or
something just gives you a drink it puts
it on your tab like there's a sense in
which they're creating more dollars
basically you know Ian says he wants to
buy you know my bottle of water uh or
you know this this bottle of water so I
say okay I'll give you a loan to
purchase it I as the bank then just type
in to to the owner's account you have a
dollar
and then Ian owes me a dollar but I
never actually transferred a dollar to
anybody right oh yeah yeah so maybe the
way to think about it is
um because remember we're talking about
you couldn't like use a treasury bond to
go to the grocery store you can go and
buy you know you can use a 20 Bill like
Federal Reserve Note right that's money
but you can also if the bill is 20 you
can take out your bank debit card and
swipe it
and technically what's happening is you
know Bank of America let's say is saying
oh right now Tim Poole has whatever a
thousand dollars in his checking account
he swiped that so now we'll say he only
has 980 and we'll credit you you know uh
kroger or whatever the grocery store is
around here an extra 20 in your checking
account and so you're right that's a
checking account right but I'm saying
that no they didn't need to do anything
like it's just on their computer what I
mean is if you so what I've been told is
that when you use a credit card right
there's no actual transfer of funds the
credit card swipe literally just gives
20 to the other person's account and
then nothing is subtracted from anywhere
oh okay so so right so where I was going
with it is to say so you can see the
grocery store does consider
what Bank of America says as people like
how much money we owe you if you showed
up and wanted your to empty your
checking account we would give it to you
and people treat that as good as Federal
Reserve notes right so that's different
from just you know you giving them that
bottle of water and him saying I owe you
what are ten dollars or whatever like
when when a loan is is given to somebody
that money is created
right and and the reason the reason
there's a distinction with what the
commercial Banks do is because for
various reasons the merchants in the
community treat
you know I'll use from the banks as
being interchangeable or fungible with
Federal Reserve notes whereas most other
let's let's try this they don't let's
say a bank uh so it's it's what they can
they can lend out like nine times or
ninety percent of their existing cash
Reserve well that used to be the the FED
got rid of the reserve requirements so
there so that particular thing is now
why do they do that they did when did um
it was it was like in April it was right
after the coronavirus thing hit wow
really and they this is funny they they
announced it on us they announced on a
Sunday night and in the press release
you had to go read the follow-up like it
just said we've made some other changes
and you had to go read the follow-up
press release to see that they got rid
of research requirements in 2020. so
does that mean they can just literally
create money at any point for any reason
okay so that's what I was saying before
so there's no statutory legal constraint
on what they can lend but there there is
a mechanism so
um if they lend out too much money you
know like people want to buy homes and
they'd lend out a trillion dollars for
people to go buy homes people go and
write checks in there let's just I want
to make sure we're getting as clear as
what I'm trying to get at right I don't
understand the bank isn't giving you
money the loan manifests the money upon
signature like the money is created at a
thin air for the loan's purpose
right okay
so like basically the bank doesn't
doesn't
actually go to its call First Take a
dollar out of its piggy bank and hand it
to you they just write it on a piece of
paper
they just they just poo for dollars
there and they they credit your account
with you want to go buy a car it's
twenty thousand dollars and you apply
for a loan so that expands the money
supply by Twenty Thousand right but I I
don't want your listeners to uh take
what I'm saying too far there are
constraints because if they're if
they're too Reckless any One bank if it
expands too much when there's Clearing
House transactions with other bank you
know so the car dealership that now you
deposit that check for twenty thousand
that was created out of thin air
electronically
that dealerships if they have a
different bank when they go to settle up
with your bank they're not just going to
say oh Bank of America is good for it
they're going to say send us Federal
Reserve notes or they're going to
actually say
you know with your account with the FED
in our account the feds settle up with
us so there is a constraint ultimately
that it's called having reserves so the
commercial Banks can't create Federal
Reserve notes and they can't compel the
FED to credit their own checking account
with the Fed so the FED can do whatever
it wants because there's there's no one
above the fed the FED just If it creates
money creates money period the
commercial Banks there is a sense in
which by making a loan they do but if
they do it too aggressively the chickens
come home is this intentionally
confusing
yes and I'm sitting here trying to
decide how much detail to get into or
not because I don't want to say
something that taken out of context
sounds like I'm saying something wrong
but but yes there is a sense in which
they can create Money commercial Banks
do have limits the FED has no limit the
only limit yeah the only limit on the
FED is just the price inflation gets too
high these local banks literally be like
I'm going to create a hundred dollar
bill for you Ian so you can buy that you
know expensive champagne
yes there's nothing stopping them except
if they do that too much so that's
that's money they create when Ian pays
them back where does that money go
so if they don't re-lend the funds uh
that money gets destroyed and so that's
the sense in which the commercial Banks
expand and can track credit and that's
why me says that was his theory of the
business cycle incidentally that the
commercial banking system they push down
interest rates expand credit causes a
boom they chicken out for some reason
they raise interest rates contract
credit the supply of money in a very
real sense decreases and that causes a
crash that removal of the uh reserve
requirements sounds like the US dollar
is worthless and on the verge of
imploding
so I I'm surprised more people didn't
notice it and make a big deal out of it
and it's part of the reason they didn't
is because since um the 2008 financial
crisis with all the rounds of QE
as you you may know the banks were just
sitting on excess reserves like they
were they had money pumped in by the fed
and then they didn't lend out like you
said like the 10 times multiple they
normally could have and so when the FED
got rid of those reserve requirements it
didn't change any of the legal
obligations in other words the banks
already were well above what the
requirements were so getting rid of the
reserves didn't constrain them but
you're right so some other countries
don't have reserve requirements too so
it's not like this is the one country
where that's the case yeah but it is
Petro dollar country yeah but it is um
right I was alarmed by it and like I
said the way the FED they're buying more
Bitcoin they did it on a Sunday night
and it was under the radar and and so
the United they also they also removed
the limits on savings accounts
converting them into checking accounts
basically is that what happened
right yep
what does that mean exactly you uh well
you could explain it I'm not gonna so
they they made a change where
um I believed before it was if you had
it was technically a savings account you
could only move money from that into
your checking account six times per
month and they got rid of that rule so
that there's really in practice now no
distinct screen checking and savings
accounts it basically so basically
savings were like considered not in the
money supply because you have a limit
six transactions per month from savings
to checking and it was supposed to be
that savings you know higher interest
and you put it in savings then they said
no more which means
all of a sudden the money supply
exploded and everyone's looking you've
seen the M1 money stock just Skyrocket
and everyone's like you got to
understand Tim this is funny they were
like you're misunderstanding this
they're not it's not an explosion in the
money supply they just change the way
they describe checking and savings and
I'm like yo they just said to extract
your savings like it's your checking
that is an explosion in the money supply
and it's extremely bad news for this
country to to to to to to flat out say
hey everybody you know your savings
start spending it like it's all you got
it's basically them saying like oh yeah
we're imploding and you can take like a
million dollars in your checking account
and at the end of the month move it into
savings get the interest and then move
it back
uh well if you did that you'd only get
it for the the brief time you had it in
there you know what I mean but so you're
so I'm that that's right so let me just
give you my take on that so just for the
people that uh listening
um so M1 is one measure that includes
checking accounts but not savings got M2
included savings accounts and so you're
right if you look at graphs you know
it's going along and then in 2020 all of
a sudden M1 goes through the roof and so
people were alarmed and then you're
right the apologist for the FED it was
like oh is you right-wing nut jobs
whatever you're always freaking out it's
just a statistical a redefinition but
even if you've used the old definition
M1 still went up a lot because you know
what I mean so it's still at a speeding
angles speeding up like crazy like as M2
which the definition change didn't
affect also spikes and so I think partly
Tim maybe the reason they did that was
to have an excuse so people wouldn't be
panicked by the spike you know I can't
prove that obviously but it was
convenient that people were like oh I
don't know when it was like half the
spike was because the you know the money
supply by any definition really did
Skyrocket we got it pulled up and you
can see like in uh around March of 2020
the straight Spike just goes straight up
between from April to you know the month
of April is a straight line up and
they're like you know the rules were
changed and how we described things but
if you look after that April 2020 until
now the difference between before the
spike and after before the spike it's
like this after this bike it's like that
I mean you guys can see it you don't
even use my hand but it's like it's
slowly going up major spike and then
it's skyrocketing and after the rule
change and are you looking at M1 yeah if
you pull up M2 I don't know if you're
threat what you're looking at but M2 is
not affected by the definition change
and so you can see M2 also spiked in
April 2020 right to show this isn't just
a definition they really did pump in a
bunch of money it's not as pronounced in
M2 but you can't see there is a spike
and you can see that from then till now
it is increasing the money supply is
increasing faster than it was beforehand
right so there's the one shift like
you're saying and the rate of increase I
didn't I didn't know about that fraction
that Reserve restriction right it was
right all at the same time period but
they started doing that if I had known
that I would have bought way more
Bitcoin and also like the FED started
buying stocks you know like they did a
lot of stuff because everyone's freaking
out about coronavirus and so the FED
guys always paying attention right wow
okay well I'm not going to give anyone
Financial advice but I keep you know I'm
we've been expanding the business and my
attitude is like hire people you know um
you know expand our facilities get more
equipment and people are like you know
don't you wanna like you there are
questions about how fast we should be
trying to expand and what we should be
trying to build and I'm like look I'm
not going to sit around on this stuff
when inflation's as tight as it as it is
we're like we had Max Kaiser on the show
and he said real inflation is probably
closer to 14 do you have any opinions on
the inflation rate in that capacity I
mean this is anecdotal but when I go to
the grocery store now even and I'm not
talking Whole Foods I mean just like
Walmart and whatever I can't get out of
there without spending 200 I don't even
buying me dude we went to the grocery
store the other day and we filled up our
cart and the final bill was like 30
higher than it was a few months ago and
I was just like whoa and I'm like I'm
looking at the receipt like what did
what happened oh yeah but um you know
anyway and also they're doing tricks too
with like the packaging like you're not
getting as much Cheerios in your boxes
right and the the cardboard is is
thinner if you've noticed that like
there's doing all sorts of things right
now I'm just saying like the last thing
I want to be holding on to is US dollars
so I bought you know some crypto where
uh just making sure that we're not
sitting on the money and we're expanding
the business it's like I don't want just
money sitting in the bank now we're
gonna make sure we have the right
cameras All Right microphone microphones
we're looking at
um we just hired someone uh we hired
another person today help us expand and
produce more content make things go
faster
there's a period in my life where I'm
like I'm I was always very much just
save save save now it's like get off
dollars invest it in something else we
gotta be careful about hiring because
they're we're gonna need to pay them
more eventually because with the
inflation isn't gonna isn't gonna cap
like the land that you get or the
cameras that's good but and people next
year are going to be need to be paid 20
or 30 percent and will need to be paid
more to cover their costs too so I'm
saying like
instead of just holding on to I mean uh
I don't know if this is did mines make a
public announcement recently I don't
want to say anything it's not public I
don't know I don't know to be honest
yeah so but but there's a lot of there's
a lot of companies that are announcing
um they're getting off Fiat oh yeah yeah
25 is now 25 of their of their uh
balance sheet balance sheet is now in
crypto wow I think you're gonna see way
more of that and you know they're like
China's Banning crypto I'm like shut up
they ban crypto every other month they
started a central [ __ ] they started a
cryptocurrency and then banned all the
other ones yep nice the US has got its
plans for its you know coin or whatever
I don't know I I don't think you know
all of these Ultra Millionaires and
billionaires who have bought into
Bitcoin are planning on losing it right
especially overnight so whenever these
stories come out it's always the poor
people who sell off their
cryptocurrencies I'm not giving any
advice you do whatever you want to do
I'm just saying the last thing I want to
be sitting on is is fiat currency we
want to hold things that will be good
Investments and hedge against the CR
like this is we're in a death spiral as
far as as far as I can tell just to
clarify did China actually they started
a crypto essential cryptocurrency I read
that you said I didn't yeah I didn't I
didn't go deeply into fact checking to
it I saw it it's almost like that's why
they made it illegal
I don't know man
I'm giving advice to anybody just what
are your personal opinions on the state
of the US dollar
sure so I I should uh admit this that I
I was very worried after the financial
crisis in 2008 and so I was you know
going around is my role like affiliate
with the mises Institute and just in
general as an economist and I was
warning people about the stuff we were
talking about like how the banks create
you know fraction reserve and so forth
and I thought you we were going to see
higher Consumer Price inflation earlier
and and so I even you know I had a
public wager with another come and and I
lost that and guys like Paul Krugman
were running Victory Labs making fun of
me if you like you would mentioned
Wikipedia my Wikipedia entry is like I
was born I lost that price inflation bet
and then you know maybe now I'll be on
Temple's show that'll be the three
things that they they mentioned in my
life but
um but in there you know I'm gonna say
well I think the rest of the world
investors were just misanticipating you
know I mean like I do think the dollar
is going to crash in our lifetime for
sure I think it's going to be a lot
sooner than that just because every time
a crisis hits now their solution is they
throw trillions of dollars new dollars
at it and so unless us they've stopped
doing that you know I think it's like I
said we've we've seen it now with our
own eyes like it it was kind of weird
and you know guys like me were you know
people were calling us chicken littles
and whatnot so I I sort of was mute
about about it for a while because it
you know it didn't come when I thought
it was going to but at this point
clearly prices are rising rapidly around
the country if last year beginning of
last year you bought Steel
chlorine Cars computer chips
cryptocurrency
you'd be set for life I mean if you
bought Bitcoin last year like beginning
of last year and you said I'm gonna put
all my money in it right now you would
never have to work again like the amount
that it's gone up since then is
absolutely insane have you studied a
debt recall at all like the history of
it over the the Millennia I think the
ancient Greece had a debt recall do you
mean like where they just reset
everything is that what you're saying I
mean I haven't studied it in the Bible
yeah where they'll they're like bring us
all of your danish bars and Jubilee like
every 50 years Jubilee in the Bible and
so yeah like is that what I mean
inevitably I'm looking at this like like
it just is like I'm staring at a big
pink elephant and it is that this Fiat
system is going to crash
right so I
to me I think that's partly tied in with
this whole great reset and everything
like I think the people running this
system know that they're you know
they're kind of pushing it to the Limit
and that's why they're trying to get
ahead of it and you know this is going
to happen and then they're gonna they
have things in the wings that they're
going to bring in to replace
the dollar is what I think ultimately is
going to come down like they'll use
BlackRock and then seize all the
BlackRock assets blackrock's assets and
then they'll have all the land and then
they'll start renting it out to people
for cheap or just for their slave labor
or something
I mean I don't know about those
particular details but but yes I I think
they they do want to move to a society
where there's a few bit you know
multi-trillion at that point dollar
companies in League with powerful states
and you know and they they kind of own
all the real estate and whatnot and
everybody else is like a surf like we
said and so they're you know and that I
won't use US dollars at that point
yeah you get a little book you'll get an
app and the app will be like did you get
your loaf of bread this week
to me another thing I see is like
they're trying to get everyone off cash
and I mean just little things like when
I go to the ATM now it the options it
gives me for withdrawal it only goes up
to 200 you I can still type in at a
different screen a bit more but 20 years
ago it offered 300 right now we just
said like that could go in one visit to
the grocery store so it's what you would
think it would let you take out 700
right now is it just a default option
but it doesn't so I think they're trying
to wean people off of holding cash and
get everyone's swiping cards because
they can I I think that uh special
interests politicians uh nonprofits want
the labor shortage it's forcing kiosks
and self-checkout so there's there's a
big conversation about you know how do
we if we've got the potential for kiosk
ordering at fast food restaurants right
how do we transition people out of these
jobs they're going to get mad when they
lose their jobs nobody wants Luddite
riots right so what happens is hey look
we got this opportunity there's there's
people are freaking out let's now just
start
switching all these things over to
self-checkout to self-service to kiosks
and then no one's going to complain
about losing their job because we're
giving them unemployment benefits right
and they're also what that's the push
for Ubi and everything that they're
they're yeah you're right I think
they're trying to get the public use to
the idea that every month you just get a
check from the government and then
you're happy right and then you sit at
home and you communicate people through
your screens and we regulate that flow
of information they'll be more miserable
than ever than they've ever been when
that happens oh sure but purposeless
confused angry yeah I got this feeling
like we talk about currency I think of
electrical currency and the the future
of currency is electricity and fusion I
keep thinking about Fusion like it's
like they they're the government or
whoever is in charge is afraid that if
people get the power of fusion that it
would be too dangerous to give the
individuals infinite almost near
infinite electricity but I mean cold
fusion maybe but what other way could
there be then currency is already energy
currency is always energy is a
electricity is a form of currency so are
dollars but I think dollars are becoming
defunct dollars represent energy
they don't represent anything anymore no
they they represent energy they used to
represent gold and silver for one the US
Dollars backed a sort of by oil it's the
Petro dollar but it's also the the the
it's it's currency and value has always
been the energy to to you know that
someone needs for some kind of outcome
so initially we had wood we had coal we
had all these different various forms of
energy
when we would trade with someone we want
them to exert their energy towards us
for some reason so when you say the
future of currency is electricity I'm
like we already have the Petro dollar
it's already you know very much so about
fossil fuels to power all of our
machines and all of our systems so
already energy is backing our currency
but oil is heavy so like if I was like
hey hey neighborhood I want some food
I'll I'll give you some of my
electricity so you can power your house
and heat your home like those are things
that really matter having electricity
having heating like like petroleum for
heating your house but it's heavy you
can't it's that's why we develop money
in the first time electricity there's
lots of ways to make electricity what
are the prince what's the principal way
we make electricity
oh no you'd have to get a I mean there's
lots of ways yeah you burn stuff that's
one way to do it but the principal way
we get electricity is cold
we burn coal and other fuels and now
natural gas to pressurized systems
so yeah you're saying it's heavy but
electricity is actually the after
product of the fossil fuels
so yes my point is that the fossil fuels
generate electricity electricity is
already partly but it's more than just
that combustion kinetic energy we
convert fuels into into motion that's
not just too heavy to use as currency
though that's the problem with it you
need lightweight that's why we developed
digital currencies why we develop dollar
paper or cotton dollars because you can
carry it around electricity is extremely
difficult to move in store I know right
now it is batteries and I think that's
intentional that's I don't want to go
down the conspiracy route but I think
that this stuff's being suppressed
because they want to they want to limit
the power of the individual
all right well well let's see what the
super chats have to say if you haven't
already sent us a Super Chat smash that
like button subscribe to the channel
don't forget go to timcast.com because
we are going to have a members only
segment coming up after the show just
for all of you amazing members who
support our work and let's read what do
we got here
all right let's see
deprived dolphin says Hey crew a judge
recently ordered that my work mandate
vaccines exception for medical and
religious I'm refusing they will have to
fire me
well good for you for standing up for
what you believe in and it's unfortunate
that we've come to this
all right let's see one two says any
reason you haven't mentioned the illegal
50 000 illegal votes in the audit and
yes they are illegal there's no way
around it uh namely because I'm
researching it uh people were like Tim's
not gonna talk about it well look man
I'm not gonna take any bold claims and
just outright read like here's what it
said I need to actually talk to some
people it's not something I can easily
do especially to be you know uh to be
fair
today was particularly hectic here with
the like the projects we're working on
but yes
um I've read a little bit I've not read
enough to be confident to opine on
Arizona's audit I can just put that put
it that way for now but I'd like to
actually get maybe like you know Bannon
to come back or something and then we
would do like a podcast episode of
timcast.com I've had Matt Brainerd on
the show we've had Steven on the show we
put that stuff on timcast.com where you
guys are able to see it uninterrupted
and unimpeded YouTube is a Minefield but
at the very least YouTube provides that
bridge from YouTube to the website to
other outlets so that the information
still persists in the ecosystem
all right
B Anderson says Tim you said something
in your earlier segment sang along the
lines of they are not going to ask for
help then filter out the ones they don't
want it's not entirely true Beggars are
being choosers I'm not sure what you're
referring to
Beverly Baum says I love you guys but I
miss Luke Luke was on his way here when
he suffered an unfortunate uh Trucking
accident oh geez no I don't know exactly
it was terrible he was just like hey
I'll be there Saturday then he said he
couldn't make it because he was having
car trouble
so uh Luke will be returning and it's
all it's it's perfect timing too because
we are really close to the new studio
being done the construction is almost
entirely done we just need to set up the
supports for the table once we do that
though then we've got to do the camera
positioning we're gonna have like wall
mounted cameras it's gonna be really
really awesome the lighting is amazing I
don't know if you guys have watched the
Vlog but the lighting is a ring of LED
lights around the ceiling so it's like
perfectly lit it's amazing
all right let's see what do we got here
John Eakin says how would you feel about
dropping the business tax rate from 25
to 5 if companies evenly distribute the
other 20 among its employees eliminate
tax deductions and if companies don't
then their tax rate would be 30 and make
Social Security opt-in
did you catch all that yeah I mean I
would like to make the business tax rate
zero percent
um and so you know but if he's given
options to lower it uh as far as Social
Security yeah I have a whole uh article
people Google you know Robert Murphy
Social Security reform I think you'll
you can find it where that's what I've
tried to do there's because what happens
right now with Social Security is I
think if you allowed people to opt out
they would get a higher you know rate of
return on their investment you know just
private sector right and also too the
the government could borrow I don't know
if it's true right now but a few years
ago when interest rates were really the
government could have borrowed on better
terms from just private lenders than it
was implicitly paying workers in other
words when you when they take your
social your payroll taxes your
contributions
and then they promise you benefits down
the road and implicitly they're forcing
you to lend them money right and so they
were actually paying a higher rate of
return on that than they could borrow in
the you know out in the regular debt
market so it was like a win-win thing
where let people opt out and that would
just you know it would it would fix the
finances or it would improve them and
then allow people more flexibility
all right Andrew Kramer says did you
guys see that Colonel Stuart scheller is
being incarcerated for speaking up about
the military leadership's failure
regarding Afghanistan I did not hear
that you guys hear that oh I didn't hear
that okay that's crazy
Joseph Henson says it's been a hell of a
ride boys
yep true that Trevor Ellis says evening
Tim and crew from Canada as a
construction contractor I've been
refused service from local suppliers
because I refused the jab 20-year
relationship gone the fear-mongering is
real up here
oh yeah man
all right James Johnson says just
watched Stargate episode that alternate
Earth Dimension had suspended all assets
of democracy
almost had an anxiety attack
you ever see a Stargate SG-1 I I have I
don't know that episode though there's
an episode where uh it's in I think
season two maybe I'm not sure maybe one
um Daniel goes through what's called a
Quantum mirror and he goes to an earth
that's under alien attack so they've
suspended basically all rights and
they're alike we have no choice they
were riots they they wouldn't support
the war effort we're about to be wiped
out by an alien race and so you're like
watching the American president these
people give you their justification
whether like we have we have to do it
otherwise we die they had to divert like
80 of all electricity towards a system
to like defend themselves so everyone's
working around the clock slave labor
otherwise the Aliens destroy the planet
and FYI if aliens attacked right now we
are doomed because we sit on a stupid
centralized electric grid come on
seriously they'd come and they'd be like
oil production over and then we'd be
like oh no what do we do
all right
I bloodroot says grandpa with dementia
passed Saturday alone in an NJ Hospital
luckily my dad got to see him a week ago
Hospital won't let priests in to perform
last rights he's cremated but no
funerals wakes allowed anyway thank you
for keeping me sane love y'all that is
brutal man I am sorry to hear that this
this is
it's it's a purge man it's a culture
Revolution it's it's just everything all
rolled into one we are watching a slow
motion fifth generational uh um coup
Revolution whatever you want to call it
in every facet's political it's cultural
it's Financial it's happening right
before our eyes in slow motion I feel
like we're watching the puppets dancing
and that we have the opportunity to
build the puppetry the Puppet Master
with technology and the code software
code but a lot of it's what's what the
puppets are doing when in reality you
should be focused on the puppeteer
yeah it surprised me how fast they I
wouldn't have guessed a year ago that
they would have federally put out like
the vaccine mandates and whatnot I'm
surprised be given the opposition to it
that how aggressively they're pushing
that
all right let's see we got Toby Walker
says there are numerous open source
versions of Unix but yes Linux was
originally a hacked and reverse
engineered Unix enhanced by Richard
stallman the GPL licensed a special
thing please check it out should we make
line of torval to Saint
he built he built Linux well um he saved
a bunch of Corporations Untold sums of
cash
I can't remember what store I was at
it's a big chain store and their self
checkouts were running Linux I mean they
all do but something happened where it
crashed it was very obviously you could
see the Linux screen and then I thought
it was funny and I was like oh it's
Linux and like one of my hacker friends
was like why would they spend money on
closed Source proprietary software when
Linux is free and I'm like oh yeah so
when they've got to operate you know 500
000 terminals at all of their chain
stores around the world use the free
software instead of paying ridiculous
sums you know so there you go
crispy Kate says Tim have you seen the
quote talk while it's still legal shirt
Rihanna wore she's also siding with
Nicki Minaj the culture war is turning
or maybe
I don't know maybe these people have
never trusted the government you know
maybe these these you know uh I I mean
these people as in like Rihanna Nicki
Minaj and you know Lil Wayne This Crew
this group of individuals and friends
not to mention I think it's fair to
point out Joe Biden saying the Tuskegee
Airmen when he meant Tuskegee
experiments but the Tuskegee experiments
a good case of you know the black
community not just in the government
glacia says to Ian a parallel internet
might even be necessary by this point
look up project new IP by Huawei that
will be voted by the itu in 2022 it acts
as anonymity and no endpoint buffers
against viruses whoa interesting yeah
they're probably
um near infinite amounts of parallel
internets running
all right
Edward saucita says covid camp in
Centralia Washington is looking for an
isolation and quarantine Strike Team
Member job Doh 5814 yeah people are
tweeting that like crazy you see that
one ah it's like a job opening for us
isolation and quarantine Strike Team
Member I didn't look it up but you know
all right let's see Andrew Roswell says
your impressive top-tier austro
libertarian podcast podcaster collection
is nearly complete now that you've had
Bob malice Dave Smith Peter Quinones and
Scott Horton the only person you're
missing is the heroic Tom Woods I knew
it all right uh have you guys been in a
room together all you guys that'd be fun
yeah no we thought it'd be too dangerous
but yeah Liberty Movement so yeah yeah
it's how they they fly to be a president
vice president yep you can't have them
all in the same place
all right let's see track media only
says ask South Korean and Taiwan how
separation's been working for them then
with the US gone how about Russia has
treated border since u.sr broke up
long-term loss for short-term gain at
best with China waiting it isn't even
that
um I'll put this way I think the U.S
breaking up is dangerous and terrifying
because China just sweeps it and takes
whatever they want so not good in the
long run but what's the alternative
International conflict with China
it's got to be something new that hasn't
been thought of yet
a some kind of messiah-like figure
returns a Superman or a saint figure
yeah like the second coming that
convinces everyone that they are the
second coming
what we're all thinkers of God man
but my hope to announce him is that like
like we say Texas or other states break
away and then yeah on paper it looks
like oh so now if the U.S Empire Falls
China takes and that certainly will
happen I think the Chinese you know will
be the people in charge of the you know
21st right Century but like a free Texas
let's say that it's so productive and
you know that they really are free you
know the freest country on Earth then
that in other words the statists
underestimate the power of actual
freedom and so yeah on paper they're
like oh yeah go ahead and break away you
Eddie what are you gonna do 30 million
people or whatever but 30 million free
people can do a lot more than they
realize
yeah Turk Longwell says Tim Ian doing
live searches was a good call well that
was entirely Ian he brought his computer
up one day and started searching for
stuff correct it's good for us and him
lol yeah that's for sure great guest too
sir thanks for all the different
perspective F Sour Patch Kids right what
I win oh yeah I have more followers than
they do but
um aren't you a big fan of Sour Patch
Kids I am so it's kind of hard for me
but you just decided one day to be mean
to them I did yeah Stan t-o-o says Mr
Murphy would it be possible for the
states to create free trade zones is
there a way to limit government overage
but still be a pseudo Nation
okay so I'm not sure if if he's talking
about the context of our discussion of
secession so clearly like if tax states
we're going to break away then yeah I
would tell that the Texas government at
that point maintain free trade with all
the other states you know and maybe
Washington to punish them would not do
that just like with brexit like that was
the big that was one of the things that
you know the European Union said is well
if you guys break away you're not going
to have free trade and then I don't know
what the status of that bluff is at this
point but yeah I mean as an economy free
trade standard that's one of the things
that made the U.S so productive and Rich
was that internally it was giant free
trade zone so if if any of these places
do break away politically still have
free trade with all and you know
relatively open you know coming and
going so you know so that's that's the
thing too to maintain a free Society
you're just politically severing that's
the thing it's you're not it's not
isolationism to say we're going to stop
sending our money to Washington right
I mean we're already seeing the country
breaking apart with California being
like no official travel to any of these
places right
drivers in in Texas aren't going to be
able to deliver uh goods to New York
where there's vaccine mandates because
they're not under the same rules unless
they get vaccinated
all right Sonny James says my
sister-in-law a ADN when the National
Guard came in for the pandemic when they
had no Staffing short when they had no
Staffing shortages she said they were
ineffective mostly stood around to the
point they used them for menial tasks
like charting civil jobs are just
different hmm
all right
Emily mower says as someone who has
lived my whole life in New Hampshire Ian
needs to shut up about my state
what did you say about her state that
was bad I don't know oh you called them
all stupid that's right yeah Ian was
like do we answer the dumb and we're
like Ian stop I've never been in here I
think I've been through New Hampshire I
like New Hampshire a lot actually
all right the Raptor is Talent with a
big old Super Chat thanks appreciate it
says Ian I disagree with your options
first in order to escape the fiat
currency you have to have a lot of it
you have to have a lot of it to work
with not everyone has that second it's
nearly impossible to get the funds to
escape the power grid and third
cryptocurrency as I understand it only
works in a society that does that does
not have a concept of scarcity um
um why is that last point I'm not sure I
understand that last point though
cryptocurrency only works in a science
society that does not have a concept of
scarcity
no Bitcoin is a scarce resource yeah
right I don't think it'd be the other
way around so I don't know what they're
saying like that's the whole virtue of
Bitcoin is it's absolutely scarce there
and there's a whole bunch of different
types of crypto some like Dogecoin
slowly grows some slowly shrinks there's
uh what is it like is defy like there's
a deflationary token that is just you
buy it and then it's guaranteed to
deflate so it's Hardware that's the way
to do it that seems like a silly reverse
kind of it disincentivizes holding it
that's the key you want to not hold
currency you want to keep keep it moving
well no but
like a currency that's slowly uh
Vanishing becomes more and more valuable
so people will hold it and you create
more I I don't know you can't credit
that's a point there's there are certain
tokens they made that slowly burn every
time a transaction happens a portion of
it gets destroyed so that over time
there's less and less and if there's a
culture building around it and more
demand for it but a shrinking Supply the
value goes up so you could buy one and
then wait a year and then it'll
naturally be worth 10 times or something
he's right that what I was saying isn't
uh triage techniques these things that I
said like getting off the central grid
getting your own food supply these are
like endemic Solutions but as a triage
of what to do right now I don't know I'm
at a loss if you got
I'm listening I don't know I kind of
feel like we can sit here and freak out
about China and those other countries
all day and night and I think it will be
really really bad but it just kind of
feels to me that the path we're on
there's there's no exit ramp like Texas
is already doing the ATF law thing where
they're like we can do our own
suppressors ATF B Dam New Hampshire is
overtly like we want to secede a handful
of people in New Hampshire but the free
state project very much so California I
mean they're banning travel to other
states already people like States in
this country are like we don't like you
we don't want to work with you so if if
this just continues the same way it's
been going It ultimately just results in
States being like yo we out
and then what
I think we'll be fine here in the US for
some time but if China becomes you know
stays on top and begins exerting
influence in other states they'll
instantly get influence on the west
coast where they have tremendous
pressure and then they'll slowly start
coming in Europe will be too weakened to
do anything and then China becomes the
global dominant superpower with military
bases everywhere let us not forget the
cartels at Calderon shout out last week
fantastic episode go check it out I
highly recommend if you didn't see it
yet but I mean that's like a government
itself and it's right on the border and
within our country
all right see uh m c o f k i says tigtow
Texans going their own way that's right
I like it
Kennedy Marine detailing says the
Tyranny Athens impose on others it
finally imposed on itself thucydides
very interesting
Sarah says Conch Republic 1982 true
secessionist movement in Florida Keys in
response to federal government overreach
I don't think about it you guys know
anything about what's it called you know
about it I don't know about that the
Conch Republic 1982. no
Logan Culver says Tim today I joined you
in the 35 year old Camp have you watched
the Monopoly on violence yet Mr Murphy
here is excellent and it love you guys
Dave Smith 2024 and then there's a I
think it's a black flag and a gorilla
excellent this year says from Contra
public.com it's a micro nation declared
as a tongue-in-cheek succession of the
city of Key West Florida from the United
States and it's been maintained as a
tourism booster oh for the city you guys
ever hear of Christiania in uh it's in
Copenhagen in Denmark yeah yeah it's
like the free zone it's a small little
area that doesn't abide by any of the
laws or whatever and I guess
you just go in there and then you're it
says now leaving the EU when you walk in
and I guess the restaurants there don't
pay taxes or something I don't know a
whole lot too much about it I've
actually been there several times really
cool place good good french fries I
think I had schnitzel I can't remember
but yeah it's this cool little place
where people who live there and it's
like um
secessionist Anarchist community so it's
not tongue-in-cheek they really don't
pay business taxes and whatnot that's
that's what I was told there's a skate
park there you can just walk in it's
like they built the skate park and it's
indoor and you just like go in there and
skate it's fun and then there's some
businesses that operate in there and
my understanding is they just tell the
government to screw off
yeah
a bunch of houses there
yeah see I think you know you guys are
right that it in practice probably
instead of like a formal vote and
reference you know it it'll be more just
people just not complying with you know
local people especially if they're in
rural communities but it's not going
along with stuff it's not it's not I
don't think it'll be conscious I don't
think it's going to be one day someone
just goes like you know what I hereby
decide I'm not going to follow I think
one day someone's going to be like you
know
there haven't been any feds coming
through our part in a long time I
haven't seen what they do and you think
about this way when people just drive
cars and they speed right everyone
speeds five miles over and they're like
I'm not gonna get pulled over sometimes
the cops do but it's because people
don't have confidence in the government
the police to actually it'll stop
everyone going five miles over the limit
so everybody just does it right and then
it's safer to go Five Mile you want to
match the speed of all the other cars
even if they're going over the speed
limit that's the safest thing you can do
is match traffic speed if the if today
every cop said we're gonna pull over
anyone going over the limit they would
not change a thing they do not have the
manpower to pull over every single car
when there is a culture built around
going five miles over the limit yeah I
think if if say speed limit's 60 and
everyone's going 85 and you're going 60
you'll get pulled over because you're
not you're not being safe so that's
sometimes but yeah they could argue you
were like you're putting the traffic at
risk because you weren't going to the
flow and then you'd be like they were
speeding
you know but the point is it's just
people doing it so what happens when one
day
you know people in Texas are like we
always do X
and then the FED one day is like you
can't do X they're gonna be like you
can't stop us there's something we
always do no one there has faith in the
federal government to stop them so they
just keep doing it the feds can't do
anything especially desperation if
people are are unemployed and they're
poor and they can't pay things then they
just don't because they can't can't
means that it is impossible so you could
see that you see like Civil Disobedience
through desperation
B Walsh says I'll uh he says your
statements he says a Lee your statement
I'm not sure he's referring to that
everything has a label reminds me of a
Pirates of Caribbean quote Barbosa said
the world used to be a bigger place and
then uh Jack Sparrow says the world's
the same there's just less in it
interesting there's more people
James Lindbergh says FedEx is straight
up losing my packages lately yes I've
said the same thing have you noticed
that FedEx announced they were rerouting
600 000 packages per day due to a driver
shortage yeah so we've had like just
tons of stuff that we've ordered just
not show up
but I'm like yo I'm not even worried
about it because I I've been paying
attention everything's falling apart
already you know so I'm just like yep
that's to be expected I guess
yeah I haven't noticed that with FedEx
per se but just lots of things
anecdotally yeah just you go to the
grocery store and there's holes my local
grocery store has redesigned itself to
be carrying a lot less inventory and I
think it was because it just it jumped
out before and so they like got rid of a
lot of shelves and whatever so yeah it
it does look like the economy is
retooling itself so get by with fewer
workers like you were saying with with
the kiosks and whatnot as well I wonder
if everyone's going to have their own
personal drone that you send out for
delivery when you order something you'll
send it and it will go to the place to
pick up the thing and bring it back to
you
Angela McArdle says Bob what do people
mean when they say they believe natural
rights are real
um well I mean there's a in a
Libertarian tradition there's the the
tradition of natural law so I I think
um she's saying is opposed to merely
just though it's a consequential or
utilitarian thing that there's a sense
in which no people really do have these
rights and it comes from natural law
whether you believe in God or just the
nature of you know human beings and
their Essence so I I think if someone
says that that what they're trying to
stress is just like two plus two really
does equal four that's not just a social
convention we don't just say that
because you know the economy grows
faster if we all pretend that it does
like it really does there's an absolute
there so I I think if I'm understanding
her question that she's delineating some
people believe in rights like that
really is something intrinsic to human
beings by their their nature as opposed
to this is a a fiction perhaps or a
convention that leads to you know things
we like yeah
tyrannus says who made the painting
behind the guest the canine skull
monster that is the Snow White Zombie
Apocalypse art I don't know the artist
but that is a comic series by Brent
Lengel that I uh I helped Kickstart and
there's a couple of them and so we got
this this big awesome post I thought was
really cool because I I thought it was
fun I think the art is fantastic and uh
what you can't see so most of you can
see the the creepy G Prime 85 George
oxopolis paintings all over the place uh
or I should they're digital I don't know
they're not paintings but we do have a
painting we got of like this cool Aurora
Borealis you can't see it's uh actually
maybe I think that shows yeah yeah yeah
you can see it when Ian sitting in the
other chair so we actually have more
than just Joe Biden you know eating kids
or like stealing the Blackness from a
woman that is our theme apparently and
we're definitely going to do some more
art with the new studio room we're gonna
do like a 3D printed Tim cast thing
that'll be a lot of fun or maybe resin
printed all sorts of stuff we can have
like a cycling Art Center that's like
changes every week or something we're
gonna put little shelves with little
stuff on it maybe like the gorillas over
there on the Shelf things like that so
we have a slightly bigger room in the
new studio it's going to be fun it's um
actually maybe a little narrower but a
lot longer well a little bit longer yeah
we're in an A-frame that other one has a
flat roof but it's higher so it's not
the A-frame it's not as high as the
A-frame right it'll be interesting it'll
be interesting but uh yeah check it out
it's a Snow White Zombie Apocalypse
J Rich says buy crypto now or be a slave
to those that did straight up time is
running out Jay Rich that's Financial
advice people are gonna now file suits
building like J Rich told me to buy
crypto no kidding
all right let's see flying raptor Jesus
says we don't need secession we need the
country ran like it was supposed to be
every state governs itself and the FED
has no power over them they have too
much power and they make States turn on
each other
yeah the the the the feds too has grown
too too uh encumbering I think you know
when the idea was like a loose federal
government it made sense the states did
their thing
now it's just you know the federal
government is basically the country and
no one cares about the states anymore
yeah just to give people an anecdote of
how much so that's the thing like people
when they re when you learn in school
like about checks and balances it's
always like the federal level but
federalism used to be the big thing like
the difference between what the federal
government could do versus the states
and just to give a quick example my
understanding is the Eisenhower
Administration when they built the
interstate highway system they actually
had to defend that by saying oh well we
got invaded it'd be easier to move
troops around so National Defense that's
how the federal government has the
authority to build highways like that
was the level of discussion whereas
later when they someone asked I don't
know if you guys heard this some
reporter from like a conservative news
site asked Nancy Pelosi where in the
constitution does it give you guys the
authority to do Obamacare or Affordable
Care Act and she said are you serious
are you serious like she thought it was
a joke like what do you mean wearing the
concert like that was the level
the federal government could just do
things right like the idea that she had
to justify like no it's it's you know
Healthcare of course
Stephen Whedon says Tim do you think
there will be a solar flare next year
I have no idea is there going to be a
solar flare next year there's lots of
solar flares all frequently right should
we build a faraday cage big heart I
thought we were going to build a fair
day I don't know where to put it we'll
do it the new the the new uh Place yeah
we'll build about we'll create we'll
make it we should make science center
you know we should do it should be a
faraday cage with a small Faraday cage
inside of it and then a faraday case
cage inside of it oh yeah so in the
triple layer Faraday defense will have
like a laptop and a cell phone yeah
because in the land of the solar flare
destroyed computers the man with a
laptop is king
um
laughs
Sonny James says Rockefeller once
believed oil could cure cancer
this robotics of the future proponents
think the same thing my thing is we've
seen how the state treats non-essential
workers already I have no hope for what
they do to us when the robots actually
take over our jobs well haven't you guys
played um
Detroit become human or what it was
called where like the the robots become
sentient and then you know
they're trying to escape they're being
oppressed
all right let's see
Matthew hasselhorst as I told the
leftist peer at work about Ed Calderon
on your show he didn't believe the
violence is as bad as it is on the
border because Ed is on your right wing
show he says the border is the same
under Biden that's just factually not
true correct yeah under trumpet was bad
the worst we'd seen in a long time
um I believe it's substantially worse
now and it was worse sooner
interestingly under Trump there was a
major spike seeing some of the worst
levels of illegal immigration but Trump
was freaking out about it trying to stop
it so at the very least you could say he
had that
but with uh with Joe Biden The Surge
actually happened earlier and Joe Biden
literally said we should search the
board other people want to come should I
mean
that's a quote we had Alex Jones on the
show he said it and we looked it up
all right let's see we got
wait what's this
Derek Elwell says did that guy spend
twelve hundred dollars on three
identical super chats really where I
want to see that oh I don't know if I
see those
I don't know
yeah no that's not that's not true I
think you you have incorrect data that'd
be great though everyone give us all the
super chats
Caleb go forth says hey Ian I'm from the
Youngstown Ohio area I'm a welder would
be cool to talk about the big
resignation of cops in the area and the
Rust Belt in general would also like to
give perspective on being mixed in
America interesting
well um you check the spin the UFO email
don't you yeah I do spin the UFO at
gmail.com General show inquiries and
tips
all right
Brandon MCN says Tim we have we have to
have an open platform solution I work
for one of the big it providers and
they're all having integration
difficulties interesting
yeah fediverse is something we're
working on right now and it's coming
along swimmingly nice I think it's
Simplicity too it's gonna be a lot
easier to do it's just about
coordinating it at this point
all right let's see we'll grab a couple
more
Jack straw says ask Bob to do karaoke in
a bonus segment
do you sing yes I do oh really is that
is that I I thought that was maybe like
an inside joke or something or a no I I
used to after like mises events I was we
would like take the kids this is my
younger days when I had more energy bar
oh okay all right there you go there's
some footage of Me on YouTube so yes I
do sing very cool Tom balzer says Bob do
you plan on moving to Texas or are you a
bystander in the secession movement
we're actually moving to Florida for
family reasons so I I did realize that
yeah if I'm pushing the Texas thing
that's going to sound but you know I I
still think Texas should secede
all right under 100 calories says Tim
soon with the rising unemployment it
sounds like the plot for Detroit to
become human hey you see you just
brought it up there you go
all right we'll do uh we'll just do uh
one more
Adam V artori says you guys should ADV
China on as a guest they lived in China
for a while and have some great insights
on China and its government fear Chinese
soft power not its military and I think
that's exactly what we're experiencing
soft power economic culture role they're
turning our movies into Chinese
propaganda I mean they they got it they
got our basketball Stars our
billionaires all saying oh China's great
because they're they're getting value
from it that's the weakness in the
system there was I forget the name of
the movie there was a movie out recently
with Arnold Schwarzenegger and Jackie
Chan in it and it was like you could see
um you know some action film you know it
was a Cheesy action film whatever it was
okay but there were Parts where it was
clear that the actors had been speaking
in Chinese and then they dubbed the US
and so presumably in China they did the
reverse so I thought that was a great
harbinger of the future of like the
melding of you know like major
Blockbusters and that in other words
like 30 years from now I think the way
right now it's like oh yeah America runs
the Blockbuster Enterprise I don't think
that's going to be the case anymore you
yeah you're gonna watch your movie with
with English subtitles and it's me and
Mandarin exactly yeah and again some
people say oh so that's the way whatever
whether you think that's a good or bad
thing I'm just saying I the people who
poo poo you know the idea oh China's not
going to do much look at their military
you know but you're right they're not
gonna literally they're not gonna have
to drop but they already are buying up
they own a lot of the U.S treasury debt
they're buying up real estate so they
they don't need to come in and drop
bombs to you know take over in us in a
soft way yeah I was a point of thinking
that they they did this strong this this
big Flex like Hey we're gonna ban crypto
didn't even budge the market yeah China
this this whole China season yeah all
right everybody thanks so much for
hanging out it's been a blast make sure
you smash that like button go to
timcast.com become a member because not
only will we have a segment coming up
around 11 or so p.m but we have a
massive library of like hundreds of
segments with all of these different
guests check out the one we did with
Alex Jones because that was like an hour
and a half long and it was crazy and I
have no control over that conversation
because he is just you know he is a
gorilla and he controls the conversation
you can follow me personally at timcast
subscribe to this channel you can follow
the show at timcast IRL is there
anything you want to shout out Bob I
would just point people to my website
consultingbyrpm.com and that's where you
can get access to all my stuff cool
people can follow you on Twitter yep Bob
Murphy econ dude thanks for coming
dropping the knowledge oh sure thanks
this is a blast thanks for having me
follow me Ian crossland.net Ian cross on
everyone's social media thanks yeah I
really enjoyed this conversation I was a
lot quieter than usual because a lot of
it was way over my head that's what
happens when super smart people come but
you guys are more than welcome to follow
me on Twitter at Sour Patch Kids we will
see all of you in the member segment
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out bye guys